on va pouvoir
reprendre qui défend l'amendement
652 madame
torignia bon et je regrette bien qu'on
puisse pas trouver une solution pour
éteindre la climatisation donc je
continue il s'agit par cet amendement de
défendre l'apprentissage du français en
prenant en compte le les personnes
handicapé parce que effectivement les
les personnes handicapées ont besoin de
d'un enseignement adapté ça
aussi monsieur le ministre n'est plus là
pour me répondre à la question par
rapport à l'éducation nationale c'est
bien
dommage donc quand on doit enseigner à
des à des personnes handicapées il y a
par exemple des dyslexiques des
dyspraxiques et cetera il
faut une compétence
particulière madame la rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président alors madame lap é
en fait votre amendement est satisfait
dans les faites puisque vous le savez
l'OFI prend en compte les situations
individuel c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'il y a un entretien individualisé qui
est fait avec chaque personne en début
de parcours et donc vous savez ce
rendez-vous il est mené par un auditeur
il permet à la fois l'évaluation de la
situation personnelle mais dans sa
globalité de prendre en compte
finalement ses besoins notamment vous en
aviez parlé tout tout à l'heure sur
l'emploi la formation et du coup ça lui
permet ensuite de pouvoir s'orienter et
en plus de façon adapt pour prendre en
cause la situation éventuelle de
handicap et pour avoir en proximité en
plus une solution qui réponde à ses
besoins donc ce sera une demande de
retrait ou sinon défavorable madame
tourgia en fait ce que vous me dites là
enfin vous répondez pas vraiment à la
question parce que vous me dites qu'on
va prendre r compte leur leur handicap
mais vous ne me dites pas si en regard
il y a des enseignants prévus et ça ça
ça je trouve ça étonnant puisque en fait
on on lit que l'enseignement va
être va être prodigué par des
associations toutes les associations je
regrette ne disposent pas d'enseignants
spécialisés pour un enseignement adapté
donc en fait vous ne répondez pas à ma
question ben non
monsieur Gouffier oui pour venir en
soutien de de la rapporteur qui avait
plutôt une réponse claire sur le fait
que c'était déjà satisfait et qu'à
travers effectivement l'accompagnement
individualisé il y avait une orientation
vers les personnes en capacité
d'accompagner ces personnes handicapé
qui effectivement ont des besoins
spécifiques donc la demande de retrait
se justifie du fait que on va dire le
dispositif tel qu'imaginé qui va se
mettre en place prévoit déjà cet
accompagnement donc nous voterons contre
cet amendement si jamais il ne il venait
à ne pas être retiré je monsieur Pradal
je vais le mettre au voix merci merci
monsieur le Président bien sûr nous nous
partageons ce souhait de de pouvoir
offrir aux personnes porteurs de
handicap quel que soit le handicap le la
l'accès à à cet enseignement du français
mais pour autant je crois comme l'a dit
Madame la rapporteur le sujet est déjà
traité et puis aussi moi j'ai j'ai une
grande confiance dans la capacité
d'adaptation parce que je crois que
c'est cours de français mis en place en
vue d'atteindre un niveau qui sera fixé
par décret il va falloir aussi accepter
que nous apprenions à marcher en
avançant et que très certainement des
adaptations seront réalisées par les
gens qui dispensent ces formations par
les associations et donc je pense que le
retrait est la bonne solution pour
permettre à ce dispositif de se mettre
en place de façon
équilibrée alors qui vote pour qui vote
contre sont
rejetés
le
1469 merci Monsieur le le président ravi
de de vous retrouver toutes et tous euh
enfin ravi de vous retrouver cet
amendement est un amendement de notre
collègue taché sur l'offre de formation
qui propose que l'offre de formation
linguistique intègre tous les demandeurs
d'asile notamment ceux ne provenant pas
de la liste des pays d'origine surûr
l'objectif est de faire bénéficier
équitablement ces catégories d'individus
à apprentissage de la langue française
afin d'intégrer dignement l'ensemble des
demandeurs d'asile sur le territoire
français je crois que c'est un
amendement de bon sens comme dirait
l'autre madame la rapporteur alors en
fait le le but de de cet article premier
c'est vous l'avez compris renforcer la
formation linguistique des étrangers
signataires d'un cire or en fait vous le
savez seuls les
réfugiés et les bénéficiaires de la
protection subsidiaire euh peuvent le
faire mais pas les personnes qui
seulement ont déposé la demande là là
c'est dans dans dans le temps c'est en
fait c'est pas du tout ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui et en fait c'est c'est pas
pertinent d'octroyer le bénéfice en fait
de d'une seule en plus composante du
cire à des personnes qui en fait n'ont
pas la possibilité encore de le signer
donc pour toutes ces raisons c'est un
avis
défavorable monsie Bernardis non mais
attendez en en quoi ce serait embêtant
que quelqu'un qui ne parle pas le
français qui a juste fait une demande
d'asile commence à la
prendre que c'est c'est
ça non mais d'accord c'est pas dans
votre machin faut signer un papier le
contrat n mais dans l'absolu dans
l'absolu je c'est pas grave au pire il
parlera mieux
français et peut-être peut-être que ça
lui permettra de mieux faire ses
démarches d'ailleurs ou de ou de de
faire valoir ses droits tu V faire je je
comprends pas ce ce ce sectarisme faut
absolument mettre les gens dans dans des
ces pour qu'ils puissent avoir accès à
la langue alors que vous n avez dit que
l'accès à la langue était impréalable
enfin bref je on a l'impression que par
des des arguments spécieux ou ou ou par
ou par des des dédales administratifes
vous cherchez à faire en sorte que le
moins de gens possible puisse remplir
les critères y compris de langue ben je
veux dire on va finir par croire que
vous êtes
xénophobe alors je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté
le
1470 défendu madame la rapporteur alors
la certification qui est demandée par
cette amendement en fait elle est elle
est déjà prise en charge donc je me
permets de vous renvoyer à l'avant
dernière alinéa de l'article
r413- 13 du cza en fait qui répond déjà
euh à votre amendement je me permets de
vous le lire hein lorsque l'étranger
obtient au test des résultats supérieurs
au niveau donc A1 ou qu'il est constaté
lors de l'évaluation intermédiaire ou au
terme de sa formation qu'il a atteint le
niveau linguistique visé il lui est
proposé de faire certifier son niveau de
français les frais et là c'est ce que
vous demandez les frais de cette
certification sont à la charge de l'État
donc c'est satisfait donc ce sera une
demande de retrait ou alors défavorable
puranalysis je Seris tenter de dire que
vous manquez pas d' r mais en fait c'est
du R et alors si si je dis pas de
bêtises r C'est c'est c'est du niveau
réglementaire et donc là l'objectif
c'est de le mettre au niveau législatif
pour se donner la garantie que si demain
d'aventure quelqu'un voulait juste d'un
d'un simple désidératar réglementaire
normatif
c'est le ministre décide de plus prendre
en charge il pourrait le faire alors que
si c'est du niveau législatif il a pas
le choix que de le prendre en charge et
de le faire voilà alors
bon je sais pas si c'est un r amendement
mais il m'a l'air bien réel celui-là
quand même et je pense qu'il faudrait le
le le le voter parce qu'on essaie de se
donner un maximum de garantie parce
qu'en général avec avec les
gouvernements auquels on est confronté
on on voit que l'application de la loi
c'est pas toujours évident alors
l'application du du
règlement parle même pas je mets au voix
qui vot pour qui votre contre rejeté le
1302 qui le défend madame Rego merci cet
amendement vise à rappeler que quand un
jeune majeur a déjà effectué une année
de scolarité
peut-être que notre système
scolaire lui transmet tout ce qui est
censé être
contenu dans le contrat d'intégration
républicaine à savoir des valeurs
communes la vie en société et cetera et
donc notre collègue r vous propose de
passer à une année scolaire histoire
d'être en cohérence ou alors ça
signifierait que nous considérerionion
que l'école n'a aucun aucune valeur
d'intégration et de transmission ce
serait qu quand même fort dommage madame
la rapporteur
oui alors bien évidemment l'école a une
valeur d'intégration sauf que les
raisons pour lesquelles je suis
défavorable à cet amendement alors la
première c'est que là en fait on on se
cale sur un an d'étude et on sait que
c'est rarement suffisant pour que un an
d'étude puisse permettre une maîtrise de
la langue nécessaire à une intégration
complète et là ce qui est proposé c'est
3 ans ça offre au contraire une
perspective temporelle beaucoup plus
réaliste pour développer une compétence
linguistique solide
ensuite 3 ans d'études dans un
environnement francophone vous j'imagine
que vous en conviendrez he permettre non
seulement d'apprendre la langue mais
bien au-delà de s'immerger dans la
culture les valeurs aussi qui sont les
nottres et donc c'est essentiel à notre
sens pour une intégration rien réussi et
donc vous comprendrez que c'est
forcément moins valable pour une année
que pour 3 années que c'est forcément
plus plus bénéfique et enfin le trè
point dans le cadre européen de commun
de référence pour les langues atteindre
un niveau de compétences linguisti
adéquate nécessist généralement plus
d'un an d'apprentissage donc pour toutes
ces raisons ce sera
défavorable madame
rugol euh oui j'entends vos vos
arguments madame la rapporteur mais je
reste un peu interloquer si si vous me
dites qu'une année d'étude euh les
personnes la passent à ne pas parler
français je me demande bien ce que font
tous nos élèves en Erasmus les élèves
qui partent en année de césure comment
font-ils pour suivre des cours vivre
dans un pays interagir s'ils n'ont pas
de maîtrise de la langue du pays dans
lequel ils sont si votre analyse c'est
qu'une année d'étude en France ça
n'apporte rien en terme de maîtrise du
français alors ça veut dire que vous
expliquez que tous nos étudiants qui
partent à l'étranger leur année ne sert
à rien c'est quand même un petit peu
gênant comme
justification madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président
dispenser du contrat d'intégration
républicaine les majeurs étrangers ayant
effectué une seule année scolaairire au
lieu des trois habituellement requis ne
nous paraît pas être une proposition
raisonnable parce que dans l'exposé des
motifs il est indiqué que des des
valeurs sont transmises aux élèves par
les personnels bien sûr que les
personnels font correctement leur
travail mais la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est est-ce que ces valeurs sont
assimilés par les élèves et c'est ça en
fait qui nous pose problème je pense
qu'on ne peut pas transiger sur les
précautions que nous devons adopter
quand on regarde l'explosion du nombre
d'atteintes au à la cité cette
augmentation est constante depuis
l'assassinat de Samuel pati rien que
pour l'année scolaire 2022-2023 on a
atteint un record avec 4710 atteintes à
la laïcité et donc je pense nous pensons
que pour assurer une meilleure
intégration républicaine et pour une
meilleure familiarisation avec nos codes
culturels et pour éviter tout
séparatisme il ne faut pas aller vers un
assouplissement il faut garder ces tro
années monsieur le rapporteur général
oui vous voyez ma chère collègue
ISH Diaz comment
monsieur bernalis s'il vous plaît
monsieur le rapporteur général qui a la
parole voyez ma ma chère collègue Diaz
vous voyez comment nous passons de la
question de l'apprentissage du français
à l'assassinat de Samuel paatti en
environ 18 secondes ce qui fait quand
même un raccourci mental assez assez
significatif me semble-t-il non pour
répondre à Sandra régol en quelques mots
si la personne a acquis le français
avant les 3 ans tant mieux tant mieux là
on parle bien de la simple signature du
contrat elle n'a pas l'obligation
d'apprendre le français pendant 3 ans si
elle l'quit avant tant mieux enfin il
n'y a absolument aucune difficulté et
ensuite Sandra rigole et ensuite nous
parlons là de l'enseignement secondaire
français vous avez donné quelques
exemples qui correspondait plutôt aux
établissement d'enseignement supérieur
vous avez parlé notamment des d'Erasmus
pour l'enseignement supérieur la règle
actuelle vous la savez peut-être vous la
connaissez c'est un an il me semble que
c'est assez équilibré c'est-à-dire pour
l'enseignement supérieur c'est une année
complète d'ailleurs ce sont des
dispositions qui qui date de 2016 rien
n'a été modifié en l'occurrence dans par
le Sénat ni par le gouvernement donc la
personne va signer elle s'engage pour 3
ans si elle acquierre les fondamentaux
de français d'ici les 3 ans tant mieux
évidemment chacun s en sera
réjoui exceptionnellement madame
Caraman merci monsieur le Président 30
secondes je j'entends bien ce que vous
dites monsieur le rapporteur la réalité
elle est complètement différente c'est
même pas une année on a d'énormes ENF un
grand nombre d'étudiants qui sont
inscrits que courant de l'année n'ont
pas leurs papiers c'està dire que les
procédures et le SU ben oui mais si à un
moment donné ils perdent chaque fois des
délais pour pouvoir continuer leur
inscription la réalité dans les
préfectures ce n'est pas celle-ci c'est
ça que je voulais
dire pardon charm car pardon mais nous
sommes pas du tout sur ce sujet il
s'agit du de la signature du contrat
d'intégration républicaine il ne s'agit
pas du tout de l'attribution d'un titre
de séjour en rien alors vous avez raison
mais pas sur ce sujet là mais de façon
générale je vous reconnais que vous avez
souvent raison le 1302 qui vote pour qui
vote contre il est
rejeté le le 651 qui le
défend il est
défendu bah il faut vous réveiller plus
vite he madame Martin ça va non ça va
pas vu la manière dont les débat se
déroulent stop
qupp côté c'est défavorable
défavorable mais ça va pas non donc vous
voulez pas je sais bien que l'exercice
démocratique vous pose un problème mais
parole et je vais quand
même il est
rejeté le 1689 madame la rapporteur
alors merci monsieur le Président c'est
donc un amendement de suppression de
l'article prier bis vous le savez mes
chers collègues c'est un ajout qui a été
fait au Sénat et en fait il vient
limiter à trois renouvellements
consécutifs les cartes de séjour
temporaire qui portent une mention
identique à à notre sens cet amendement
est fortement attentatoire au droit de
séjour c'est un facteur d'insécurité
juridique injuste pour les étrangers et
qui vient en contradiction avec les
objets d'intégration de notre pays à
notre sens il créent des barrières
artificiellement et supplémentaires par
rapport à leur intégration et finalement
ils viennent à rebours de ce projet de
loi une telle mesure risque par ailleurs
d'accroître significativement la charge
de travail des préfectures et je crois
que Madame Mariette vient d'en parler
c'est un sujet qui est extrêmement
important et les étrangers concernés
devant engager des procédures
alternatives pour maintenir par ailleurs
leur statut légal en France donc pour
toutes ces raisons
je suis défavorable donc à cet article
et favorable à l'ensemble des
amendements de suppression auxquels je
joins le mien je vous remercie alors
j'ai également un amendement de
suppression monsieur Lucas vous en avez
un aussi merci monsieur le Président bon
on avait entendu gentil avec les gentils
méchants avec les méchants là c'est
c'est quand même beaucoup méchant avec
les gentils quand même et surtout pas
réglo avec les réguliers puis que cette
article était voté il plongerait de
nombreuses personnes en situation
régulière depuis plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années dans l'irrégul pour des
motifs complètement arbitraires
parilleurs je me permet de de signaler
monsieur le Président parce que la
soirée commence il y a pour l'instant
une ambiance globalement sereine que
notre collègue Martin a cherché ses
notes ça nous est tous arrivé depuis le
début de cet examen ça fait des heures
qu'on est là elle aurait pu défendre son
amendement pour la clarté du débat pour
que les collègues puissent se faire une
idée c'est bien qu'on puisse défendre
nos amendement il y a personne n'a eu de
logique d'obstruction sur l'examen de ce
texte depuis le début on dit beaucoup de
défendu les uns et les autres et cetera
c'est quand même bien qu'on puisse
s'exprimer sereinement les uns et les
autres c'est un conseil je n'ai pas
vocation à vous dire comment présider
cette commission monsieur le Président
mais quand même ça serait bien que
madame Martin a pu s'exprimer sur son
amendement monsieur alors Monsieur
Castellani c'est le suivant
ouais ben on est toujours dans une
logique justement de de de suppression
nous considérons que le projet de loi
initial tel qu'il est durcit déjà
suffisamment les critères d'accès à
chaque à chaque titre
voilà
monsieur porte alors qui défend
l'amendement de monsieur porte monsieur
cou monsieurintou j'avais monsieur
saintou qui voulait défendre aussi le
675 monsieur
Couci merci monsieur le Président alors
je vais pas utiliser les prétextes
humanitaires qui ne semblent pas
émouvoir grand monde ici pour justifier
de cet amendement et je vais vous aider
dans cette tâche
avec la focale sur prétexte utilitariste
des étrangers sur notre sol puisque il y
a beaucoup de gens parmi vous qui se
prétendent vouloir défendre les intérêts
des entreprises par exemple des petites
entreprises je suppose pas du CAC 40
encore qu'il y a un camp qui le défend
bien mais euh ici pour les petites
entreprises on a un souci c'est que on a
un manque de main d'œuvre dans certains
domaines dans mon département par
exemple pour les les viges hein pour la
la la collecte du raisin et bien les
vendanges manque de personnel manque de
de salariés de travailleurs d'ouvriers
et les vignerons nous disent on a un
problème on a de la main d'œuvre
disponible des gens qui veulent venir
travailler mais on a beaucoup de mal à
faire en sorte qu'il soit dans une
situation légale et finalement on
narrive pas à les faire comment dire
régulariser et pourtant on a besoin
d'eux ils sont là ils veulent travailler
alors moi je vous dis pourquoi limiter à
trois fois le le le N merci Monsieur
valallot monsieur
Solignac merci monsieur le Président je
crois qu'on sera un certain nombre à
être d'accord pour supprimer cet article
iniique je rappelle que ce projet de loi
dans son titre euh vise à améliorer
l'intégration gager que jusqu'à présent
on a plutôt dégradé cette cette
intégration et que si euh l'on devait
adopter cet article-là on lui mettrait
un cût presque presque fatal à
l'intégration euh puisque cet article
introduit une nouvelle insécurité
juridique particulièrement grave et en
quelque sorte il consiste a à dire à ces
étrangers on vous soumet à des épreuves
au demeurant accru et si vous échouez
vous perdez votre droit au séjour au
mépris des règles de droit à la vie
privée et familiale donc il est
absolument impensable de maintenir dans
notre projet de loi ce ce type de
disposition madame fessillon merci
Monsieur le le Président je rejoindrai
les mots à la fois de la Défenseur des
droits mais aussi de de la rapporteur
qui dit que qui qui disait que cet
article en fait représenterait vraiment
une attaque euh inédite au au droit au
séjour donc je veux alerter les
collègues particulièrement sur sur cet
article qui effectivement pose une
insécurité juridique extrêmement
importante qui demande des exigences
tout à fait accrues mais aussi
totalement disproportionné et qui pour
moi est vraiment un un article qui qui
marque chez celles et ceux qui l'ont qui
ont cherché à mettre en place une
volonté vraiment de tourner le dos à une
ambition qui est pourtant une ambition
française une ambition de de partage de
valeur et uneamb une ambition qui est la
volonté de pouvoir intégrer des des gens
venus d'ailleurs dans dans notre pays ça
ça semble peut-être fou à certains
collègues mais en fait c'est une belle
ambition c'est une ambition qu'on est
capable de relever quand on y pose les
bonnes conditions et vraiment là il y a
la volonté de rejeter complètement cette
ambition et je crois que c'est part
particulièrement
grave madame
Dupont merci monsieur le Président dans
la ligne des collègues qui viennent de
s'exprimer effectivement cet ajout du
Sénat est en lien malheureusement avec
de nombreux autres et et je le crois en
définitive stigmatise les étrangers
présents sur notre territoire et tous
les moyens sont bons en quelque sorte
jusqu'à l'interdiction de
renouveler ces cartes de séjour donc je
souhaite comme vous comme de nombreux
nombre d'entre nous que c cet article
soit supprimé madame
brocard merci monsieur le Président si
on est un certain nombre même pas tous à
partager la même volonté d'intégration
il faut aussi justement le but c'est que
ça fonctionne donc il faut prendre en
compte tous les facteurs et donc la
suppression de de cet article vise aussi
à considérer et ben les étrangers qui
sont en territoire rural et euh moi on
m'a souvent fait remonter qui devait
parcourir un certain nombre de
kilomètres pour accéder en particulier
au cours de français encore une fois on
a eu la discussion tout à l'heure donc
faisons en sorte de nous donner les
moyens de l'accès au cours de français à
tous les étrangers où qu'il se situe euh
sur notre territoire métropolitain ou
outreem et même en donc dans nos milieux
ruraux merci Madame
gevenou oui merci monsieur le Président
euh le groupe Renaissance présente là
aussi un un amendement de de suppression
parce qu'on comprend pas très bien en
fait la la logique de cet article qui
permet de ne enfin qui qui interdit en
fait le renouvellement plus de trois
fois consécutives d'une carte de séjour
temporaire pour le même motif ça
signifie au fond que un étranger qui
disposerait par exemple d'un titre de
séjour de travail par exemple ne
pourrait pas le renouveler plus de trois
fois et se retrouverait donc face à
trois options soit celle de demander une
carte de séjour pluriannuel mais c'est
pas forcément le choix de cette personne
soit de trouver un autre motif mais quel
autre motif pourrait correspondre que
celui de qui correspond à sa situation
réelle soit d'être dans l'irrégularité
ce qui nous semble être pour le moins
curieux euh donc nous souhaitons
supprimer cet
article alors j'ai donné un j' j'avais
le même amendement donc c'est un avis
bien évidemment favorable monsieur le
Président pour tous ces amendements de
suppression merci Monsieur gilet
oui chers collègues
faut placer les choses à leur contexte
en 2022
316174 premiers titres de ses jour ont
été accordé à des immigrés
extraeuropéens c'est un c'est un
record ensuite vous caricaturez les
choses vous caricaturez les choses parce
que cette mesure elle permet de limiter
l'installation prolongée de certains
étrangers ne remplissant pas les
condition pour bénéficier d'un titre de
séjour permanent on parle bien là de
renouvellement de titre de séjour
temporaire pour un même motif donc ne
racontez pas tout et n'importe quoi si
vous ne remplissez pas les conditions
pour bénéficier d'un titre de séjour
permanent cela veut bien dire que vous
n'avez pas vocation à rester
indéfiniment sur le territoire national
il faut pas transformer les choses et
encore une fois il faut rappeler la
réalité des chiffres et ce record de
chiffres
316174 premier titres de séjour et puis
en plus avec ces amendements vous venez
piétiner finalement la volonté des frça
qui je vous le rappelle réclame qu'il y
ait moins d'immigration en France madame
jeunevard merci monsieur le Président
moi je voudrais expliquer la logique qui
a prévalu à l'élaboration de cet article
en réalité vous vous méprener sur les
intentions du Sénat de quoi est-il
question dans l'article 1er nous avons
adopté des dispositions qui visent à
permettre aux étrangers à maîtriser la
langue française qui est un facteur
majeur d'intégration et je crois sur ce
point nous étions par extraordinaire à
peu près tous
d'accord le fait de ne pas permettre
d'aller au-delà de
trois cartes de séjour
temporaire la logique vise à
encourager l'étranger à obtenir une
carte pluriannuelle et pour se faire à
maîtriser la langue française ça veut
dire qu'il a 4 ans il a 4 ans devant lui
pour appréhender la maîtrise de la
langue française s'il ne le peut pas
s'il ne remplit pas cette condition il
peut plusieurs solutions s'offrent à lui
solliciter la délivrance d'une nouvelle
carte de séjour temporaire mais pour un
autre motif mer ou alors tout faire tout
faire pour acquérir une les Monsieur
saintou Merci monsieur le Président deux
observations tout d'abord j'entends
notre rapporteur évoquer le les les
propos de la défenseur des droits et et
je m'en félicite mais je j'observe
qu'elle ne la suit pas la rapporteur des
droits sur l'ensemble des des articles
et l'ensemble de ses avis j'aimerais que
elle harmonise d'une certaine façon sa
position et et qu'elle suive plus
régulièrement la la Défenseur des droits
le deuxième observation c'est que
évidemment on a un problème si vous on
limite l'octroit de de cartes de séjour
temporaire dans le temps parce que
évidemment dans le même temps c'est la
restriction des critères pour obtenir
des cartes pluriannuelles qui qui est en
balance ce que nous a expliqué notre
collègue tout l'heure c'est que en
réalité puisque aujourd'hui on naccède
plus à des cartes pluannuelles il y a
pas de raison non plus qu'on donne des
cartes temporaires mais c'est l'inverse
le raisonnement est exactement l'inverse
c'est parce que aujourd'hui vous ne
délivrez pas de cartes plurriannuelle
que les gens sont obligés de retourner
faire des cartes chaque année et
j'ajoute que vous régleriez un grand
problème de désengor d'engorgement des
des préfectures si au moins on accédait
à la carte pleurriannuelle c'est un
problème majeur et de sécurité et de
d'engorgement du service public monie
rapporteur
général quelques quelques mots peut-être
à l'attention de Madame jeunevard en
particulier notre objectif à travers ce
texte de loi c'est d'éloigner celles et
ceux qui ne respectent pas nos principes
et nos
règles et ce seront les dispositions que
nous verrons à travers les articles 9 et
suivants et notamment la levée d'un
certain nombre de protection c'est aussi
de punir celles et ceux qui exploitent
l'immigration à des fins tout à fait
monétaires
capitalistiques ce sont les marchands de
sommeil ce sont les employeurs voyou le
cas échéant notre objectif ça n'est pas
de multiplier les situations
d'irrégularité pour des personnes qui
sont en situation régulière sur le
territoire national donc je crois qu'il
faut être très clair là-dessus nous nous
ne souhaitons pas multiplier les
situations comme le disait madame gevnou
où la personne sera dans la situation
suivante soit elle repart dans son pays
alors qu'elle pourrait y rester parce
que le motif est toujours le même soit
elle doit basculer dans l'irrégularité
et alors nous devrons d'une certaine
façon et pardonnez-moi du terme la
récupérer par la circulaire Vals ous
l'article 4 bis qui aurait été adopté
moi je ne suis pas très convaincu par
cet argument et pour terminer je
voudrais dire à Jean-François coulum
qu'il a donné quel il y a quelques
instants un exemple qui n'est pas du
tout concerné par cette disposition pour
le coup vous avez parlé des travailleurs
qui viennent dans dans nos vignes je
suis député de la Gironde et là
évidemment il s'agit d'un autre titre de
séjour c'est le titre de séjour
saisonnier il n'est pas concerné par
cette
disposition monsieur le
ministre je je madame jeunevard disait
que on se méprenait sur ce qu'a voulu
faire le le Sénat mais je pense qu'on se
méprend si vous me le permettez des des
volumes et de ce que l'on souhaite faire
dans politique migratoire dans vos
interventions tant à gauche qu'à droite
les titres de séjour c'est 3,5 millions
mais les titres de de moins d'un an
c'est
380000 c'estàdire que c'est très peu
c'est 10 % de tous les titres pardon
monsieur le député mais vous dites des
bêtises ce que nous faisons c'est que
nous donnons des titres
pluriannuels c'est 350000 les titres
pluriannuels qu'on constate par rapport
au titre de séjour c'est quasiment d'un
an les mêmes donc vous dites vraiment
des énormités ce que nous avons fait
dans l'article précédent c'est que nous
avons conditionné ce titre plannuel à un
examen de français bien la question est
de savoir si on doit refuser des titres
de cours séjour répété au-delà d'un
certain nombre c'est finalement la
question que pose madame jeunevard je
vous donnerai des chiffres en séance
peut-être plus précis mais à ma
connaissance les titres renouvelés d'un
an plus de trois fois c'est moins de 20
% de ces 10 % de ce total donc je pense
qu'on est à un nombre pas très important
alors après qu' est dans la pratique
madame jeevard moi j'entends l'argument
du Sénat je pense pas qu'il faille le
mettre dans la loi qui est dans la
pratique l'idée que comme on change de
mécanisme et qu'on va vers le titre
plannuel avec un examen de français
est-ce que les gens qui n'ont pas le
titre plannuel c'est parce qu'ils ont
raté l'examen de français par trois fois
ils ont pas pris les cours ou est-ce
parce que simplement ils veulent des des
titres de cours séjour et qu' ne veulent
pas forcément faire venir leur famille
parce que je vous ferai remarquer que en
accédant en incitant vers plurannuel
vous incitez auoupement familial je
ferme la parenthèse il y a aussi des
gens et ça dépend la qualité de ces
personnes ça dépend ce qu'ils font
professionnellement ça dépend comment
ils souhaitent vivre sur notre sol de
quelle nationalité ils sont mais il y a
aussi des gens qui veulent des titres de
premier séjour simplement sans sans
intégrer des années et des années en
France simplement ils ont des missions
où ils sont venus pour un certain nombre
de projet et ils n'ont pas vocation à
rester sur le territoire national donc
je pense que ce que vous voulu faire le
Sénat et en le soutenant ce que vous
souhaitez faire c'est de dire les gens
qui veulent rester longtemps sur le
territoire national ils ne doivent pas
déroger finalement l'esprit du
législateur en multip
de de de 1 an sans passer l'examen de
français si c'est le cas mais si c'est
le cas je pense que c'est assez mal
écrit et il faut peut-être qu'on y
réfléchisse différemment pour la séance
mais on va pas refuser par principe des
des titres de cours sé jour à des gens
qui ne veulent pas s'installer
durablement sur le territoire national
et qui veulent juste peut-être faire un
an 2 ans de plus parce que ils
construisent une centrale nucléaire qui
a pris du retard parce que ils ont tel
projet personnel sans vouloir
s'installer durablement sur le
territoire donc je pense qu'il faut
distinguer VO la nature de ces personnes
et comme je vous l'ai dit il y a moins
de des titres globaux qui sont des moins
d'un an et il y a moins de 20 % sur
l'ensemble de ces titres de moins d'un
an qui sont au-delà de de 3 ans donc je
pense qu'on peut soit réécrire quelque
chose soit s'engager peut-être je ferai
au ban en prenant une disposition
d'instruction pour distinguer la nature
de ces personnes donc je soutiens la
suppression de cet article dont j'avais
dit au Sénat que je comprenais l'esprit
mais qu'il me paraissait mal
rédigé je vais mettre au voix ses
amendements de suppression qui vote pour
qui vote contre ils sont adoptés il
suppriment vous plaisenteer ou
quoi il y a de TI de la salle qui V pour
et vous pensez que c'est pas adopté bon
c'est pas grave
allez le 183 monsieur
Lucas monsieur président très rapidement
nous nous opposons à l'exclusion de la
présemption de validité des actes public
étranger en cas de non légalisation des
10 actes cette mesure va compliquer
encore plus les démarches
administratives des étrangers et limiter
encore plus l'accès au séjours des
personnes les plus précaires comme l'a
rappelé là aussi là encore et toujours
la Défenseur des droits à l'occasion de
son audition par notre
commission euh qui défend le 681 madame
Martin alors donc puisqu'il met
puisqu'on daigne me donner la parole
donc il est il est question de de
légalisation des documents qui seraient
une exigence bon d'abord mais ça on
finit par être habitué même si on ne s'y
résout pas ça veut dire que comme
d'habitude potentiellement l'étranger
est considéré comme potentiellement
fraudeur donc il faut accumuler les
exigences à son ég de surcrois ça n'est
pas si simple que ça même si l'on
restait sur l'étape en lien avec
l'administ tion française il faut des
traducteurs qui soient habilités qu'il
faut trouver dans toutes les langues et
ça n'est pas toujours simple alors là
moi je ne sais pas s'il y a
effectivement une exigence de double
légalisation mais c'est peut-être le cas
où là il faut avoir une capacité à
susciter les autorités la représentation
des autorités françaises dans le pays
d'origine bon donc ces affaires là
deviennent extrêmement compliqué donc
c'est comme sur la question de la langue
un point plus un point ça finit par
faire Lig ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que à force il y a tant
d'exigences cumulatives que l'on crée
les conditions pour que les étrangers ne
puissent de toute façon pas ni séjourner
ni s'installer dans le
pays monsieur
vot madame car oui mon frère alors oui
par cet amendement effectivement nous
souhaitons aussi la suppression de de
cet article chers collègues parce que
cet article vise surtout à remettre en
cause une jurisprudence qui était
toujours constante puisque le juge admet
chaque fois la la force probeante des
actes d'état d'état civil étranger même
s'ils n'ont pas le fait fait l'objet
d'une légalisation enin de prendre en en
compte aussi les énonciations contenues
dans ces documents concernant l'identité
et l'âge des personnes donc cet article
qui a été introduit par un amendement du
Gouvernement au Sénat en tant exclu
justement la force probante de ces actes
dans le but de lutter contre la fraude
documentaire au moment des demande de
regroupements familiaux alors vous
comprenez que c'est d'abord c'est
injuste c'est effectivement et c'est
grave ce qui est proposé ici à travers
cet article une jurisprudence et qui
établie aujourd'hui cet article
n'apparaît pas justement souhaitable et
risque donc de compliquer encore
plusériurement la vie des étrangers dans
notre pays madame kbidi madame
kerbidi merci monsieur le Président
alors nous nous soutenons également
cette amendement de de suppression je
tiens à rajouter par rapport aux
arguments déjà développés par mes
collègues que la validité des acte
étranger elle est déjà régie par notre
droit et notamment par le Code civil et
donc pour être valable à un acte
étranger il n'a pas forcément besoin
d'être légalisé sachant que la
légalisation c'est généralement plus de
3 mois de procédure sont des frais pr de
traducteur et on vise en réalité avec
cette obligation de légalisation
uniquement allonger les délai et à
complexifier encore les démarches pour
les pour les étrangers qui vont devoir
euh faire un certain nombre de démarches
supplémentaires coûteuses et qui ne sont
absolument pas nécessaires tout à
l'heure on avait évoqué l'avis de la
Défenseur des droits si on suit à
nouveau l'avis de la Défenseur des
droits ici alors il faut supprimer cet
article et il faut aller dans le sens de
nos amendements et enfin Madame brocard
merci monsieur le Président
euh le Sénat nous introduit une
modification qui vise à exclure de la
présemption de validité des actes d'état
civil étrangers en cas de non
légalisation si on prend l'avis
contentieux du Conseil d'État rendu le
21 juin 2022 euh il a estimé que la
circonstance qu'un acte de l'état civil
étranger était est privé des faits en
France en raison de sa non légalisation
et que ça ne faisait pas obstacle à ce
qu'il soit utilement opposé aux
autorités administratives françaises au
fin de prendre en considération les
énonciations contenues dans un tel acte
notamment celles se rapportant à
l'identité à l'âge des personnes qui
sont désigné donc si les autorités
administratives peuvent d'ors et déjà
disposer d'information leur permettant
d'identifier les étrangers qui entre sur
le territoire français et bien cette
disposition paraît naturellement
superfectatoire et cette endement vise à
supprimer cet ajout sénatorial madame la
rapporteur
merci monsieur le
Président alors merci Madame jeunevar si
vous me laissez présenter mon avis donc
effectivement aujourd'hui cet article
conditionne l'opposabilité aux
administrations et juridiction française
des actes publque et décision de justice
relative à l'état civil alors
légalisation
préalable comme vient de le dire Madame
jeunevar il s'agit d'une disposition qui
a été introduite par un amendement du
Gouvernement séance publique et donc je
laisserai le ministre répondre sur le
sur le fond juste à ce stade hein pour
vous dire que notre droit instore une
présomption de validité des actes
publics étrangers alors même que nos
administrations sont confronté à un
phénomène de fraude à l'état civil et
aujourd'hui il nous paraît que la la
légalisation certes c'est une procédure
qui est contraignante mais mais elle
apparaît proportionnée et justifiée dans
l'objectif de lutte contre la fraude je
suis donc favorable au maintien de cet
article et j'aurai donc un avis
défavorable pour les amendements qui
restreignent par contre encore davantage
ce dispositif je vous remercie monsieur
le
ministre non mais vous avez parfaitement
compris le les étendu du du débat c'est
effectivement une demande
gouvernementale parce que c'était une
disposition qui avait déjà été versée au
projet de loi justice et l'avis du
Conseil d'État prévoyait que s'il était
loisible je cite le Conseil d'État au
législateur de qualifier les valeur
prant de production devant un juge ou
devant l'autorité préfectorale il ne
peut à moins de méconnaître les règles
de valeurs constitutionnelles gouvernant
le déroulement du bon procès équitable
interire la production de quelques
pièces que ce soit devant l'autorité
juridictionnelle il s'agit donc de le
limiter à la possibilité de
l'instruction préfectorale et le Conseil
d'État a donné son accord
constitutionnel si je veux dire sur
cette question qui ne remet pas en cause
la préstion de validité dont dispose par
principe je le cite encore les actes
d'état civil en droit français c'est
l'article 47 du Code civil le phénomène
de fraude à l'état civil se manifeste
dans de très nombreux cas j'en ai évoqué
tout à l'heure une partie avec la la
reconnaissance de paternité et il s'agit
des procédures initiées par des
ressortissantsétranger auin d'être
rejoint en France par les membres de
leur famille c'est 5900 requêtes qui
concernaient les questions autour des
fraudes je rappelle que c'est 14000
12000 à 14000 le nombre deoupement
familial c'est dire donc un cas
important la proportion de faux
documents de circulation de certains
pays sont énormes par exemple à Guinée
c'est 90 % des documents qui sont jugés
frauduleux par l'é missions de de
l'OFPRA notamment du fait évidemment
d'un état civil totalement défectueux ou
corrompu qui nous empêche bien
évidemment d'avoir une possibilité
d'être certain ou de présomption de
validité de ces documents donc il s'agit
pas de s'adresser à tous les pays mais
évidemment de pouvoir utiliser cet arbre
lorsqu'on sait qu'il y a des états
civils qui ont disparu par des état en
guerre ou parce qu'il y a un certain
nombre de difficultés qui relèv de la
corruption dans ces pays la disposition
donc voulue par le gouvernement se croit
proportionné et je rejoins madame la
rapporteur pour ne pas réduire encore
plus le champ de cette application qui
est déjà effectivement une application
de fermeté dans la lutte contre la
fraude monsieur chéen berger
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
m'étonne quand même de l'argumentation
tendant à vouloir supprimer cet article
que on considère que demander juste la
preuve que les documents sont des vrais
est problématique il y a pas de
suspicion quand on pose le principe de
dire il faut authentifier les documents
avec une réalité qui est celle que nous
nous couvrons une absence de de de de
stratégie d'asile ou d'immigration
notamment vis-à-vis de des pays
complètement défaillants d'un point de
vue de leur organisation
étatique l'absence d'organisation
étatique n'est pas un motif d'asile et
et finalement continuer à à prospérer
des procédures sur des documents issus
d'État défaillant c'est considérer la
défaillance de l'État comme un motif
d'asile ça n'est pas la volonté euh du
enfin ça n'est pas le sens de nos textes
c'est une mépris c'est une
surinterprétation de ces possibilités et
je pense que cet article est
bienvenu monsieur gilet
oui chers collègu les les auteurs de de
ces euh de ces amendements de
suppression de l'article premier terre
disent
que cette mesure aurait pour effet de
limiter l'accès au séjour des personnes
les plus les plus précaires pardon ça ça
a pas de sens encore une fois je rejoins
ce qu'a dit le collègue précédent la
légalisation des actes étrangers est un
instrument de lutte contre la fraude à
l'état civil à laquelle sont massivement
confrontés nos administrations donc je
sais pas collègue quand vous êtes en
dehors de l'Assemblée nationale je sais
qu'on passe beaucoup de temps ici mais
alleer rencontrer les acteurs de terrain
et ils vous le dire ils ont besoin de
cette légalisation il le récl et ça fait
bien longtemps qu'il le récl donc un
moment donné je comprends pas alors
c'est vrai que de la part de députés
d'extrême gauche qui c'est vrai sont
plutôt pro immigration on pourrait le
comprendre mais de là à être pro fraude
moi je le comprends
pas Madame
kbidi merci monsieur le Président alors
moi je j'ai un peu de mal avec
l'argumentation développée par Monsieur
le Ministre parce qu'il nous indique
que il faudrait parce que on a des
difficultés dans certains pays euh avec
les états civils parce qu'ils n'ont pas
des états civils aussi développés que
les nôtres il faudrait vérifier les
actes mais est-ce qu'on se rend compte
que justement parce que dans ces pays
les états-ciivils sont parfois
défaillants parce que parfois le bureau
d'état civil a brûlé on ne retrouve pas
les actes parce que il n'y a pas le
personnel suffisant et ben dans ces
pays-là obtenir un acte c'est déjà
difficile le faire légaliser c'est
quasiment mission impossible et moi je
je je viens du de de la Réunion et j'ai
en tête particulièrement les problèmes
qu'on a avec Madagascar à côté de chez
nous où parfois il faut attendre un an
juste pour obtenir un acte dans un petit
bureau d'état civil dans une petite
mairie au finfond de ce pays et c'est
pas de la mauvaise foi j'ai envie de
vous dire que la personne qui est
étrangère de toute façon que son acte
euh ne porte pas exactement la bonne
mention comme on voulait on sait qu'elle
est étrangère si elle était française
elle produirait sa pièce d'identité
française donc en réalité on est en
train de mettre des bâtons dans les
roues à des gens qui n'ont déjà pas les
moyens de pr les documents qu'on
demande merci monsieur le Président ce
que vient de dire notre collègue est en
réalité frappé au coin du bon sens si on
nétait pas étranger et bien on
présenterait une pièce de un document de
nationalité et on comprend bien que en
réalité ce qui est fait là c'est
absolument absurde parce que en réalité
c'est précisément parce que les
personnes viennent de pays dans lesquels
il n'y a pas d'état et en général s'il
n'y a pas un état suffisamment fort pour
avoir un état civil organisé c'est une
des grandes raisons qui le pousse à à
l'exil et bien ont fait porter la
responsabilité de l'absence de l'état
solide sur les épaules des personnes qui
demandent à à faire valoir leur droit en
France donc c'est parfaitement absurde
et en l'occurrence c'est tout à fait
injuste puisque évidemment si vous étiez
ressortissant d'un pays dans lequel
l'état civil fonctionne très bien vous
n'auriez sans doute pas besoin de de le
quitter madame givnou
oui merci monsieur le Président le
groupe Renaissance viendra rejeter ces
amendements de suppression car s'ils
étaient adoptés cela viendrait à
renoncer à un outil extrêmement
important qui nous est proposé par le
gouvernement et qui permet de lutter
contre les fraudes à l'état civil qui
comme l'a rappelé le ministre se
manifeste dans de très nombreux cas en
effet notre cadre
juridique confère une présomption de
validité qu'il appartient à à
l'administrationversé y compris lorsque
les actes d'état civil émanent d'État
dont les systèmes d'état civil sont
notoirement défaillants comme c'est le
cas pour la Guinée 90 % des actes comme
l'a rappelé le ministre et puis juste
pour dire Madame Caraman nous a dit tout
à l'heure il y avait une JIC il y avait
une jurisprudence constante du Conseil
d'État c'est vrai du Conseil d'État mais
vous savez madame carmanli que la la
jurisprudence judiciaire la dernière
décision la Cour de cassation vient au
contraire
confirmer cet article qui prend en fait
appui sur cette jurisprence la Cour de
cassation alors je vais mettre au voix
ses amendements de suppression qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeté monsieur poj
le 124 oui merci président moi je trouve
également que cet amendement apporté par
le gouvernement au Sénat est un
amendement qui va dans le bon sens étant
donné le le niveau de fraude en terme de
documents d' civil et moi je vous
propose de euh sécuriser encore plus la
procédure en authentifiant en certifiant
par un commissaire de justice par
exemple ces documents ce qui
permettraiit d'encore mieux lutter
contre la fraude mais aussi de faciliter
le travail des administrations des
préfecture et de sous-préfecture puisque
le document serait totalement identifié
sécurisé et
authentifié Monsieur Madame la
rapporteur
pardon alors merci monsieur le président
donc en fait en cohérence avec ce que
j'ai dit précédemment je ne suis pas
favorable à des dispositions plus
restrictives je l'avais dit dans le
propos liminire pour lesquels
l'administration n'a pas à ma
connaissance manifesté en fait d'intérêt
à ce stade et j'ajoute que les actes
administratifs étrangers doivent être
déjà traduit par un traducteur
assermenté en vue de leur légalisation
et pour le reste le dispositif que vous
proposez me semble très contraignant et
difficile à mettre en uvre c'est pour
toutes ces raisons que ce sera un avis
défavorable je mets au voix qui vre pour
qui vote contre rejeté le 106 qui le
défend défendu madame la rapporteur
défavorable je le mets au bois qui vote
pour contre rejeté l'article 1emier TER
qui vote pour
contre adopté l'article 2 madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président donc
cet article vise à faire prendre en
charge par les employeurs la formation
de français de de leur salariés
étrangers qui ne parlent pas le français
bon dans le contexte économique
particulièrement difficile que subissent
nos entreprise cet article est au mieux
inacceptable au pire totalement
déconnecté des réalités enfin je pense
que tout le monde va sur le terrain et
que tout le monde entend des chefs
d'entreprisees notamment des TPE PME qui
expriment leur désarrois face aux
charges par lesquelles ils sont écrasés
on parle bien sûr de
l'inflation de l'ex explosion des normes
mais aussi du coût exorbitant de la
facture d'électricité que vous ne
souhaitez pas réduire et donc ces
entreprises aujourd'hui n'ont pas
suffisamment de trésorerie pour
augmenter leur salariés et de toute
façon les chiffres parlent de même vous
le savez bien en matière de faillite
d'entreprisees malheureusement entre
juillet 2021 et juin 2022 on déplore la
fermeture la faillite de 33000
entreprises et c'est 50000000
entreprises qui ont fermé entre juin
2022 et juillet 2023 donc pour protéger
la compétivité de nos entreprises il
faut alléiger les charges pas les
alourdir et c'est la raison de notre
amendement de suppression madame la
rapporteur merci Monsieur le le
président alors je je saisis l'occasion
de de cet amendement de suppression
juste pour rappeler l'objectif de cet
article en fait il organise la
contribution des employeurs à la
formation linguistique des travailleurs
étrangers àophone afin bien évidemment
de favoriser leur insertion
professionnelle et social permettez-moi
de rappeler que l'étude de l'INC de 2016
souligne que si la maîtrise du français
est à priori n'est pas un obstacle à
l'obtention d'un premier emploi en
France on sait finalement que la
méconnaissance de la langue est un motif
important
d'inadéquation entre le profil des
étrangers et le poste qu'ils occupent
dès lors on se doit de trouver des
dispositions justes efficaces afin de
remédier à cette difficulté qui affecte
le marché de l'emploi ensuite l'article
2 il permet aux employeurs dans le cas
du du plan de développement de compéten
de proposer à l'ensemble des salariés
hophon des formations en fleu d'autre
part les
signataires salariés halophon qui
signent donc un cire ils peuvent
comptabiliser comme temps de travail
effectif les actions qui permettent le
suivi de leur formation linguistique et
celle-ci si elles sont considérées comme
réalisées sur leur temps de travail et
donc avec le maintien de leur
rémunération enfin cet article aussi il
prévoit que pour le seul suivi des
formations en fleu du compte personnel
de formation de l'étranger donc
signataire du cire l'autorisation
d'absence pendant le temps de travail
est un droit et dans les deux cas la
limite d'un plafondeur sera déterminé
par
décret je tiens à rappeler aussi que le
Sénat dans un premier temps avait
supprimé cet article en commission et
qu'il a ensuite décidé de le rétablir en
séance
publique on entend la crainte que les
les sénateurs ont pu manifester hein
d'une charge qui serait trop lourde pour
les entreprises et en particulier les
plus petites d'entre elles je tiens à
souligner deux points le premier c'est
que pour les PME de moins de 50 salariés
il existe déjà un mécanisme de soutien
via des fonds mutualisés de plan de
développement des compétences et donc
d'ailleurs les deux premiers alinéas de
l'article 2 permettent la prise en
charge de la formation fleu dans ce
cadre en revanche et ce sera l'objet
d'un amendement la rédaction actuelle de
l'article pose une difficulté s'agissant
du secteur de l'emploi à domicile et des
particuliers employeurs que nous avons
auditionné en commission des lois et
donc je proposerai à ce momentl un
amendement qui permettra d'adapter
l'article 2 en conséquence et donc vous
le comprendrez cet article 2 il
contribue de façon extr extrêmement
forte à renforcer notre politique
d'intégration et il a donc par
conséquence toute sa place dans le texte
je serai donc défavorable à sa
suppression tout en vous proposant de
corriger quelques effets de bord afin
d'en garantir sa bonne application je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre oui
c'est un article important également que
cet article 2 et j'ai du mal à
comprendre les arguments du
rassemblement national sur cette
question je m'explique en quelques
instants nous pensonsnous que l'employur
si il a évidemment la possibilité le
droit et la demande de faire venir des
étrangers en France pour pouvoir
travailler ne peut ne pas avoir qu'une
vision capitalistique de cette personne
puisque le faire
venir c'est aussi avoir des conséquences
pour l'ensemble de la société il a une
responsabilité lorsqu'il choisit
d'embaucher quelqu'un qui n'est pas en
France qui n'est pas français ou qui
n'est pas étranger qui apparemment a
déjà une autorisation de travail il fait
venir une mainœuvre étrangère et je
m'étonne que le Front national le
rassemblement national pardon puisse
accepter l'idée qu'on ne met pas de
contrainte à ces entreprises là c'est
assez incohérent avec votre discours
politique deuxièmement aujourd'hui il y
a une contribution pour ceux qui
intègrent les étrangers dans le dans la
façon dont on fonctionne aujourd'hui
c'est une contribution à l'OFI donc la
solution habituelle c'est une taxation
c'est un versement et on on laisse la
puissance publique organiser la
formation et la contribution au cours de
français par exemple puisque ce que l'on
souhaite c'est qu'évidemment ces cours
de français valeur de la République soit
fait dans le cadre de l'entreprise mais
on le sait bien c'est une astuce de
garçon de main parce que l'étranger qui
souvent travaille dans un métier pénible
lorsquil est fait lorsqu'on le fait
venir par une entreprise française et
encore une fois dans des conditions où
il ne parle pas français où il où il
n'est pas intégré à la société française
fait une heure de transport 1 he dem de
transport imaginons la femme de ménage
par exemple elle fait 1 he dem de
transport pour venir nettoyer les
bureaux à Paris elle refait 1 he3i
transport pour repartir chez elle elle
habite pas à Paris centre on peut
l'imaginer c'est assezisoire de penser
qu'à 14h ou à 15h elle aura le temps de
la préfecture à l'association pour
prendre des cours de français elle ne le
fait pas et si l'employeur ne se sent
pas un peu une
vocation une vocation sociale alors
personne ne le fait alors on a inventé
avec cet article 2 le 1 % intégration
comme on faisait jadis le 1 % logement
comme on demande de contribuer les
entreprises dans la vie de leurs
salariés
j'attire l'attention aussi du
rassemblement national et des autres
groupes politiques bien évidemment mais
je voudrais souer pour rassemblement
national parce que ça paraî
particulièrement incohérent quand
faisant cela non seulement on donne des
obligations en plus quand on embauche un
étranger qui ne parle pas français mais
par ailleurs on rend moins compétitif le
fait de prendre un étranger qui ne parle
pas français qu'un Français ou un
étranger régulier parce que si un
étranger régulier intégré ou un Français
travaille 35 he celui qui est halophone
ne peut pas travailler 35 he il
travaillera 35 he moins les 600 heur
d'obligation donc c'est plus intéressant
de prendre quelqu'un qui est déjà
intégré ou qui est français donc de
quelque manière que l'on soit sauf si on
est juste hyper libéraux hyper
capitalistiqu on ne peut pas être contre
cette mesure parce qu'elle permet par
obligation aux entreprises d'intégrer
les personnes qu'elles font venir le
fait d'appeler une manœuvre étrangère en
France n'a pas que conséquen que
capitalistique les gens après se loge il
ils vont vivre dans dans la rue ils vont
alors culte ils vont évidemment avoir
une vie de famille ils vont inscrire des
enfants à l'école il y a donc des
conséquences pour la société il n'est
pas normal que le temps de travail ne
permette pas l'épanouissement du salarié
et de ce point de vue c'est une vocation
sociale certains répondent par la taxe
nous répond par l'obligation et
troisièmement comme ça a été très bien
dit par Madame la rapporteur les petites
entreprises et moins de 50 salariés ne
sont pas concernés parce qu'elles ont
les OPCO alors il est vrai que les
grosses entreprises les grosses PME les
grosses multinationales elles doivent
répondre du M d'œuvre qu'elles font
venir sur le S national donc d'abord je
pense que c'est un article 2 qui est
extrêmement important je vois bien qu'il
gêne aux entournur une partie pas pas
tout mais une partie du patronat c'est
pour ça sans doute grâce à son
intervention que la la commission du
Sénat l'ait dans un premier temps
supprimé je crois que dans la grande
sagesse du Sénat après avoir échangé et
entendu les arguments à l'unanimité
quasiment ils l'ont rétabli et je pense
que c'est une vocation sociale vocation
patriote que de pouvoir le retenir tant
pour les étrangers qui doit avoir la
formation de langue de français pendant
le temps de travail que pour RRE plus
compétitif l'embauche du salarié
français ou qui est déjà étranger sur le
sol régulier donc de toute manière je ne
comprends en aucun cas la logique qui
pousserait l'Assemblé nationale à s'y
opposer sauf pour êre par principe pour
pas résoudre les problèmes mais c'est un
autre sujet je voudrais pas faireer
évidemment madame Diaz
oui merci monsieur le Président alors je
suis assez circonspecte par par les
arguments de Monsieur le Ministre moi je
voudrais juste vous dire que si des
employeurs n'ar arrive pas à recruter du
personnel la solution ce n'est pas
d'aller chercher du personnel à
l'étranger vous savez il y a 5 millions
de chômeurs dans notre pays c'est pas 5
millions de feignants il y a de la main
d'œuvre qui est mobilisable et les chefs
d'entreprise nous l'ont dit quand nous
les avons reçu en audition on peut aller
chercher les jeunes éloignés de l'emploi
on peut aller chercher les bénéficiaires
de RSA et on peut aussi aller chercher
parmi les Seigneur que vous obligez à
travailler non plus jusqu'à 62 ans mais
jusqu'à 64 ans donc les arguments que
vous présentez bon moi je les trouve
particulièrement douteux mais si vous
venez nous expliquer que que cet article
vise à dissuader le recrutement de
travailleurs étrangers bien écoutez nous
allons quand même vous faire confiance
et nous allons retirer notre
amendement alors d'accord vous vous
retirez aussi parce que vous admettez
peut-être que c'est une obligation
nouvelle à l' Gard des employeurs qui
emploient des des salariés étrangers et
qui aussi imposent à ces gens qui
exploitent peut-être pendant longtemps
des travailleurs étrangers de les
humaniser et donc d'avoir des
obligations à leur égard mais moi je
vous remercie pour ce retrait qui est
assez aussi éclairant
le 803 madame
jeunevard merci monsieur le Président
moi je j'iraai même au-delà je propose
que cette formation soit obligatoire que
les entreprises et l'obligation de
proposer à leur salariés halophone une
formation en français je pense que c'est
très important pour les salariés
eux-mêmes il peut pas y avoir de
progression professionnelle dans
l'entreprise sans maîtrise de la
langue j'aimerais bien pouvoir continuer
mais le bruit est tellement important je
je sais madame je le déplore depuis
maintenant 3 jours
allez-y donc je reprends mon
argumentation si vous me le permettez
monsieur le Président je propose par
cette amendement de rendre cette
formation obligatoire d'autant vous en
avez exclu les entreprises de moins de
50 salariés les particuliers employeurs
je pense que l'entreprise a un devoir
moral d'organiser des formations
linguistiques pour les salariés
eux-mêmes pour les salariés hophones qui
sont parents parce que je persiste à
dire que la pratique de la langue
française est essentielle pour les
enfants il faut que les enfants
entendent parler français à la maison et
il y a encore beaucoup de salariés
halophon qui vivent dans notre pays
depuis longtemps et qui ne pratiquent
pas la langue française et quand ils ne
la pratiquent pas leurs femmes ne la
pratiquent pas non plus et leurs enfants
non plus donc il y a un enjeu personnel
pour le salarié mais un enjeu familial
également merci alors madame regol votre
amendement est identique en réalité
allez-y ou oui oui eu des amendements
qui sont soutenus par le Conseil
national des barreaux et qu'on peut euh
c'est toujours bien de citer ses sources
et que l'on peut déposer parce que les
sénateurs et sénatrices en particulier
écologistes ont permis la réintroduction
dans ce texte de l'article 2 je crois
que monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
avait oublié de le préciser tout à
l'heure en en disant que le Sénat dans
sa grande sagesse l'avait réinséré il me
semble même que la porteuse de
l'amendement s'appelait Mélanie Vogel
bref
pour ce que je rajouterai à ce qui a
déjà été énoncé par ma collègue
jeunevard c'est que la simple
possibilité n'est que créatrice
d'inégalité potentielle et que c'est la
raison pour laquelle on doit passer à
quelque chose de plus précis et
puisqu'il me reste une vingtaine de
secondes je rajouterai juste pour
répondre à Madame Diaz tout puisque je
n'ai pas pu le faire avec le retrait de
son amendement que ces emplois ne sont
pris à personne les emplois en question
sont des emplois qui sont justement à
prendre et les employeurs les patrons
vont chercher la les compétences là où
elles sont en France mais aussi ailleurs
ce n'est pas l'un contre l'autre le 686
qui le défend chez les insoumis Monsieur
sintoule Merci monsieur le Président euh
alors c'est un amendement qui dit à peu
près la même chose que celui de nos
collègues regole et et jeun Var
puisqu'il est question de garantir que
les employeurs vont bien fournir ces ces
formations à la langue française parce
que comme l'a souligné tout à l'heure ma
collègue torinia pour l'instant nous
n'avons pas de garantie sur le fait que
alors que les obligations de sa
croissent en matière de maîtrise de la
langue française les moyens mis à
disposition des des étrangers pour
apprendre le français eux suivent donc
au moins nous nous nous proposons de de
garantir ce genre de formation en
mettant cette responsabilité sur les
entreprises observe aussi que dans la la
le raisonnement qui a été tenu par le
rassemblement national on voit que il
n'y a des obligations que pour les entre
que pour les individus mais évidemment
pas pour les entreprises quand il s'agit
des personnes ça il faut toujours monter
les P blanche et on a des obligations
mais à l'inverse pas pour les
entreprises je signale aussi pour la
réflexion que il y a évidemment un enjeu
de sécurité extrêmement important que il
est normal que les entreprises puissent
assumer leur responsabilité vis-à-vis
des personnes en leur permettant de
maîtriser la française le plus vite
possible notamment pour des raisons de
sécurité au travail enfin parce que je
suis un peu taquin je demanderai au au
au ministre de nous expliquer d'où vient
l'expression astuce de garçon de main
parce que je ne suis pas certain qu'elle
soit attestée et dans un débat sur la
langue française je
suisorteur merci monsieur le Président
alors moi ce sera un avis favorable
effectivement à cet amendement de de
madame jeunevar je trouve qu' va
vraiment dans le dans le beau sens et
qui vise vraiment à à favoriser cette
intégration par le Tr
donc ce sera favorable à ces donc à
l'amendement de Madame jeunevard et de
Madame regol en fait il sont identiques
parce qu'il y a juste un le sujet qui
change voilà donc ça favorable sur ces
deux amendements alors Monsieur Solignac
pardon oui monsieur le Président c c cet
article est assez intéressant surtout si
il est amélioré par quelques amendements
mais j'ai le sentiment qu'il a une forme
d'incompréhension jusque dans V rend
puisque monsieur le Président vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure une obligation
c'est le terme que vous avez employé
vous avez parl d'une obligation à
l'égard des des des étrangers et j'ai
évidemment l'article 2 sous les sous les
yeux il s'agit bien de de de proposer au
salariés allophon des formations donc
j'aimerais que vous nous précisiez ça
parce que si c'est si ça relève de de la
faculté c'est-à-dire si c'est une
possibilité pour l'employeur j'auraai
une question extrêmement simple est-ce
que vous estimez sérieusement le nombre
d'étrangers qui se verront proposer des
cours de franceç
à quel niveau vous l'estimez plus ou
moins de 1 % parce que ça restera
ridicule alors 1 % c'est la
participation de l'entreprise pour le
financer et il peut proposer il propose
donc l' l'employeur est bien dans
l'obligation de faire cette proposition
monsieur
léom monsieur
Lom non non ministre à la
fin oui de même je pense qu'on va se
rallier en fait c'est la même idée C
différents amendement celui qu'on
propose et celui ceux qui sont proposés
par Madame jeunevard et par Madame regol
je je trouve sa qu'il y ait une belle
unanimité sur le sujet pour l'instant ce
que j'aimerais savoir j'espère qu'elle
ira jusqu'au groupe Renaissance puisque
là pour l'instant c'est le groupe modem
et que sur un certain nombre de sujets
il y a pour l'instant des différences à
l'intérieur de la de la de la majorité
moi j'espère qu'on l'adoptera tous parce
que effectivement la langue est un des
des meilleurs outils de l'intégration et
de de de de l'apprentissage de d'un
certain nombre de choses pour vivre bien
dans notre pays mais ce que j'aimerais
c'est d'avoir la certitude que tout le
monde va bien le voter parce que ça va
faire une différence mais j'aurais bien
aimé avoir l'avis du ministre
d'abord d'abord j'ai monsieur nagelen
ensuite monsieur le rapporteur et enfin
Monsieur le Ministre ou Madame la
rapporteur comme vous voulez mer merci
monsieur le
Président juste pour dire que à titre
personnel je voterai contre cette
cet amendement parce qu'en fait quand on
entend l'explication de monsieur le
ministre il nous parle en fin de compte
sur les flux et en effet demain une
entreprise qui fait venir un un étranger
je peux comprendre que derrière il
finance sa formation là aujourd'hui on
parle aussi du stock et donc
d'entreprise qui potentiellement auraiit
recruteraiit un étranger sitation
irrégulière sur le territoire français
et donc et et donc non seulement et vous
avez dit derrière que ce serait pour son
propre intérêt mais on est tous d'accord
pour dire que si aujourd'hui il y a
besoin de recruter des étrangers en
situation irrégulière dans les
entreprises c'est parce qu'on arrive pas
à trouver de main d'œuvre française donc
quand il fait ce recrutement il le fait
non seulement pour son entreprise mais
aussi pour tous les autres salariés de
l'entreprise qui pourrait se retrouver
en difficulté s'ils arrivent pas à leur
trouver un collègue qu'il soit français
ou étranger et en fin de compte je pense
que le gouvernement devrait prendre
aussi sa responsabilité et financer pour
partie cette formation et qu'elle soit
pas uniquement à la charge d'entreprise
crée on crée aujourd'hui une
contribution supplémentaire aux
entreprises peu importe la taille
d'ailleurs alors Madame ou Monsieur le
rapporteur qui souhaite monsieur le
rapporteur non mais j'ai bien compris
que Monsieur léoman souhaitait savoir si
le le rapporteur général issu du groupe
Renaissance était d'accord avec la
rapporteur issu du groupe modemme alors
je je vais le le le rassurer non nous
nous avons nous avions noté que euh
autant que groupe GRP la majorité LR au
Sénat n'a pas souhaité imposer une
obligation pour cette formation
considérons au contraire que la solution
présentée par même jeunevard et Madame
régol est tout tout à fait adaptée mais
je voudrais revenir sur l'argument à
l'instant évoqué par Monsieur donc
favorable évoqué par Monsieur nagelen
par ailleurs l'État s'engage sur
l'apprentissage du français et de façon
extrêmement forte puisque cela a été
acquis d'ailleurs dès le Sénat sur la
gratuité de façon générale donc non
seulement nous sommes exigeants et nous
l'avons été à l'article 1er il y a déjà
quelques heures mais c'est la gratuité
de l'apprenti sage et puis il y a la
responsabilité de l'employeur et nous
sommes je pense à peu près tous
convaincus que cette responsabilité qui
était optionnelle au terme du Sénat peut
en effet madame jeunard vous avez raison
devenir
obligatoire je mets donc au voit les
amendements ah pardon monsieur le
ministre jeavz oublié pardon non mais je
je veux dire d'abord un à Madame regol
que sauf erreur de ma part c'est bien un
amendement du gouvernement puisque c'est
un article 2 qui était dans le texte
initial qui a supprimé la commission des
lois après que Madame Vogel et recopier
l'article du gouvernement pour proposer
un amendement identique je l'entends
bien mais mais là je crois qu' il y a il
y a petite un petit compte d'auteur à
réglé donc c'est quand même l'article
premier du gouvernement tel que déposé
au Conseil d'État voilà voilà voilà
quelques mois madame rol bon il vous a
pas interdit de dire que le gouvernement
fait parfois des choses bien et je
trouve ça formidable que vous AZ
l'amendement identique de Madame
jeunevard ça nous a surpris dans un
premier temps et finalement comme
Monsieur léomand on s'en on s'en
félicite deuxème sujet je voudrais juste
dire à madame à Monsieur nagelen pardon
que il s'agit bien de deux choses
différentes il s'agit du temps de
travail
laisser pour pouvoir apprendre le
français quand on fait venir des
étrangers ou lorsqu'ils sont sur le sol
national et qu'ils ont une autorisation
de travail et qui ne sont pas intégrés
donc là il s'agit ser d'une obligation
incontestablement mais c'est bien le
principe général et pour ce qui concerne
hophone peut proposer pas s'en propose
il s'agit bien d' unee formation qui
existe déjà dans la formation
professionnelle mais elle doit être sur
le modèle linguistique et des valeurs de
la République on verra ce qu'on définira
ensemble mais qui qui fonctionne alors
c'est vrai monsieur AG Vous avz pas tout
à fait tort c'est une obligation qui
pèse sur l'entreprise mais nous on pense
qu'elle a une vocation sociale aussi
l'entreprise et comme on n'est pas passé
par la taxe parce qu'un gouvernement
classique si je dire serait passé par la
taxe pour dire une contribution à la
société quand vous faites venir un
étranger dans entreprise mais il reste
pas intégralement dans l'entreprise il
peut peut-être changer d'entreprise
changer de département et c'est la
société c'est vous et nous où l'État qui
est à gérer cette personne
supplémentaire ça me paraît pas normal
qu'ils y contribue puisque ils y
trouvent du profit enfin je voulais dire
à Monsieur le Député que s'il va sur mot
tra d'union surannée.fr il trouvera la
définition de garçon de bain alors je
vais lui lire des les plaisanteries de
garçonb tire probablement de l'almana de
l'almana l'almana vermau ouvrage de
référence en matière de calendrier
lunaire horoscope alors vous demandez à
tout le monde qu'on vous écoute sauf
quand nous parlons mais c'est un autre
sujet
horoscope orditologie agriculture et
jeux de mots facile alors il il y a des
exemples sur la plaisanterie de garçon
de maain après on verra que il y a son
dérivé qui est l'astuce par exemple je
ne sais pas si vous allez pouvoir
l'écouter on ne peut pas dire que ce
roman de Tolstoy ne soit guerre ÉPA vous
l'aurez vous l'aurez compris et par par
parallélisme des formes la plaisanterie
de garçon de bain V à l'astuce de garçon
de bain en effet à l'esprit léger ce que
les gaz du poman sont à la parfumerie
mais je vous laisse évidemment cette
dernière assertion bon après cette
séquence Petit Robert on va voter
l'amendement madame je et Madame
c'est qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il est adopté il fait tomber
l'amendement suivant le
997 monsieur Lucas madame monsieurc
merci Monsieur le le
président que nous allons poursuivre
dans cette quasi unanimité avant d'avoir
appris la langue française on doit et
c'est bien le moins quand même pouvoir
être compris et et comprendre notamment
ces droits et et et obligations c'est
pourquoi nous proposons que
euh un accueil adéquat des étrangers qui
trouve un emploi soit garanti en
s'assurant que le contrat de travail
qu'il s'apprête à signer soit traduit
dans leur langue maternelle il nous
semble aussi que c'est un amendement de
nature à à rassembler et à coconstruire
ensemble au moins sur un petit bout euh
de ce de ce texte madame la rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
nous allons pouvoir effectivement
continuer dans cette ambiance de
concorde puisque votre amendement est
satisfait mon cher collègues alors je ne
citerai pas la définition des garçons de
bain j'espère que vous ne m'en voudrez
pas je citerai l'article L
1221-3 du Code du travail je suis
désolée hein c'est moins c'est moins
voilà c'est peut-être moins drôle et je
le cite si vous si ça vous intéresse mes
chers collègues lorsque le salarié est
étranger et le contrat constaté par
écrit une traduction du contrat est
rédigée à la demande du salarié et je
précise monsieur Lucas dans la langue de
ce dernier donc ce sera une demande de
retrait sinon défavorable je vous
remercie monsieur Lucas merci de même
que la confiance n'exclut pas le
contrôle la satisfaction n'exclut pas
l'inscription en l'occurrence dans la la
loi et comme on dit chez moi il y a les
10ux et les feux et on encourage là à
faire et donc à inscrire clairement les
choses donc je maintiens mon amendement
euh monsieur Lucas la rapporteur vient
de vous dire que c'était dans la loi
mais monsieur léomand très très
rapidement pour soutenir cet amendement
de Monsieur Lucas et je pense qu'il a
raison ça n'est pas parce que c'est déjà
inscrit ailleurs que en le précisant ici
ce serait dommage et je vous invite à ne
pas jet à ne pas jeter euh le bébé de de
Monsieur Lucas avec l'au du bain d'une
certaine manière bon et bien sur ces
bons mots qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté madame la rapporteur le 1702
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
j'avais d'ors et déjà indiqué dans la
présentation liminire donc je vais pas
revenir he sur l'article 2 là il s'agit
dans cet amendement là d'adapter les
disposition l'article 3 au secteur des
particuliers employeurs je vous en ai
déjà parlé tout à l'heure en prévoyant
notamment un un régime particulier par
décret je vous
remercie je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre adopté madame
brocard le
1278 merci monsieur le Président euh
toujours justement en ce qui concerne
euh la spécificité des particuliers
employeurs euh ça vise à introduire euh
une PR
proratisation pardon euh du maintien de
la rémunération si on prend par exemple
une aide à domicile qui a un employeur
le lundi et le mercredi et un autre le
mardi et jeudi il y a pas de raison que
ce soit que l'employeur du lundi qui euh
euh paye euh l'intégralité donc ce
serait inéquitable et c'est euh bah la
raison de cet amendement madame la
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
donc conformément à ma à ma position
hein qui a été indiqué sur les
amendements de suppression je vous
invite à retirer le vôtre euh en fait il
est d'ors et déjà satisfait c'est les
deux critères que je vous ai indiqué à
la fois les PME et à la fois les
particuliers employeurs et donc ce sera
une demande de de retrait sinon
défavorable retirer euh ben vous avez la
parole madame la rapporteur pour le 7
1734 je vous remercie alors en fait il
est identique au 1702 et c'est pour des
questions de légistique il a fallu que
je le découpe en deux donc ça fait voilà
de de votes mais ça correspond au
précédent qui vous a été
présenté
je qui vote pour mon nom de
rapporteur qui vote contre adopté
2733 et bien c'est même en 3 excusez-moi
ça n'était pas en deux mais c'est pour
maintenir votre attention mes chers
collègues donc l'endement de rapporteur
qui vote pour qui vote contre
adopté et ensuite l'amendement 703 qui
le défend alors donc l'amendement 703
nous ajoute une petite complication pour
ces gens qui plein d'espoir
imagineraient un seul instant pouvoir
s'installer chez nous dans la mesure où
vous avez imaginé que ces formations
indispensaes ça par contre nous sommes
d'accord nous sommes inquiet sur la
capacité à faire et là une nouvelle donc
inquiétude nous anime puisqu'il
semblerait qu'il faille que il finance
les salariés eux-mêmes via le compte
personnel formation bon comment fait
puisqu'il faut que le compte personnel
formation soit alimenté comment est-il
alimenté parce que les gens ont
effectivement eu un temps suffisant de
travail pour pouvoir l'alimenter mais
comment fait-on si on n pas eu le droit
de travailler jusqu'à maintenant on ne
peut pas donc à nouveau une
contradiction à nouveau une difficulté
franchement finalement vous faites
perdre beaucoup de temps en tant au
sénateur quià nous-même vous feriez
mieux de trouver une une formule simple
ramassé qui disent la France est un pays
fermé on ne veut plus être un peuple
mélangé on veut plus accueillir personne
sauf ceux qui ont la même couleur de pot
et ça serait beaucoup plus Simp Martin
madame la
rapporteur alors merci monsieur le
Président donc en fait madame Martin
votre affirmation en fait elle est
fausse puisqueen fait les formations en
fleu peuvent aussi être financé par les
employeurs donc elles sont pas que
financé par les salariés et alors en
plus d'un point de vue légistique la
façon dont vous rédigez votre amendement
en fait dans les faites ça empêcherait
de prendre en compte comme tant de
travail effectif la formation dans ce
CPF donc j'imagine qu'en plus c'est
voilà c'est pas le but recherché donc
pour toutes ces raisons c'est un avis
défavorable donc je les monsieurg
pardon je je comprends pas bien je
comprends pas bien intervention de notre
collègue parce qu'en fin de compte cette
partie de l'article vise un objet très
différent c'est c'est l'objet de la
l'étranger qui fait preuve d'une volonté
personnelle de suivre des formations
supplémentaires et donc vous vous
opposez finalement à cette volonté
d'intégration supplémentaire que
certains travailleurs étrangers
pourraient avoir au-delà des obligation
de l'employeur je comprends pas trop
pourquoi vous vous opposez à cette
possibilité que nous offront à ces
étrangers particulièrement volontaires
dans leur intégration d'un point de vue
de la langue de bénéficier de droit
d'autorisation
d'absence bien je le mets au voix qui
vote pour qui vote contre rejeté je
mettre au voie l'article 2 qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté après
l'article 2 qui défend l'amendement
écologiste le
1473 madame
regol
madameable défavorable je le mets au
voix qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté le 696 madame
torignia merci alors nous proposons
l'instauration d'une procédure de mise
en demeure permettant aux employés
deiciter des formations en français
langue étrangère je rappelle que c'est
un enseignement spécifique en cas de non
réponse de l'employur dans un délai d'un
mois la condition de maîtrise de
français ne pourra être opposée au
salariés pour lui refuser son titre de
séjour ou son renouvellement par cet
amendement nous montrons que nous
pensons effectivement contrairement à ce
que disent certains que l'apprentissage
du français la maîtrce du français est
importante mais il est important aussi
de donner tous les moyens aux employé de
pouvoir en en
bénéficier madame la rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président en fait vous
l'avez vu he l'article 2 qu'on vient de
de voter il propose une procédure qui
est à la fois simple et opérante pour
pour tous les les
étrangers qui souhaitent s'insérer par
le travail et se former par contre je
suis vraiment pas voilà convaincu par le
le dispositif que vous présentez qui est
qui se révèle extrêmement complexe
administratif
et pour répondre à votre interrogation
si le salarié il souhaite bénéficier
d'une formation en fleu et que son
employeur lui dit que ce serait pas
pertinent vu son niveau de de français
par exemple et qui voudrait pas
l'inscrire dans le plan de développement
des compétences il pourra toujours
solliciter une formation dans le cadre
de son de son CPF donc pour tous c ces
raisons excusez-moi ce sera un avis
défavorable il ser je le mets au voix
qui vote pour
contre
rejeté on passe au de B 1 madame la
rapporteur le
1690 merci monsieur le Président donc
c'est une
suppression alors l'article 2 B a donc
il il évoque un sujet qui est
particulièrement grave celui de la
nationalité française il y a de nombreux
amendements dont le mien qui propose la
suppression j'ai lu avec attention les
vôtres mes chers collègues d'cun dénonce
un amalgame entre immigration
délinquence d'autres une mesure
d'affichage
politique vous vous rappelez que la
déchéance de nationalité est une
sanction éminemment lourde qui ne
saurait être prise en charge à la légère
et elle n'a au demorant pas sa place
hein dans dans ce projet de loi je crois
que le sujet mérite un débat apaisé
entier et tout ce qui serait voilà
consacré à la nationalité n'a pas
vocation à être traité ici euh puisque
ce n'est pas dans le dans le cadre du
texte que nous examinons cette semaine
donc pour toutes ces raisons euh donc je
suis favorable à la suppression de cet
article moi j'ai j'ai déposé un
amendement identique puisque ce qui
vient d'être dit c'est que le code de la
nationalité n'a n'a rien à voir avec
cette cette euh partie de du du PGL il
est donc cavalier et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle sur tous les
amendements qui suivent qui concernent
le Code civil et l'établissement de de
l'état civil j'ai déposé des amendements
de suppression j'ai aussi un amendement
de Madame BUFF
mais je crois défendu je vous avveis pas
vu madame donc défendu monsieur Lucas
merci Monsieur le le Président
j'aimerais madame la présidente Madame
la rapporteur pardon effectivement qu'on
a des discussions apaisées c'est
difficile d'avoir une discussion apaisée
sur ce ce sujet je me réjouis des
amendements de de suppression qui sont
déposés par le président de la
commission des lois et par la rapporteur
monsieur rotillo c'est sans doute pris
pour une sorte de François Hollande
discoun en voulant remettre au cœur du
débat pu r la déchance de nationalité je
lui souhaite le même destin électoral et
démocratique que l'ancien président de
la République plus sérieusement nous
avons des lois nous avons des punitions
prévues dans le cadre de ces lois la
déchéance de nationalité est un symbole
et plus qu'un symbole qui abîme ce que
sont les valeurs de la République qui
ont suscité à l'époque où un précédent
gouvernement avait voulu les mettre au
cœur du débat public beaucoup d'émotions
à juste titre et un tel article
abîmerait aussi notre image dans le
monde la France Pat patrie des Droits de
l'Homme vous revendiquez l'universalisme
et bien si on est si on a le souci de
l'universel on a le souci d'un certain
nombre de valeurs fondamentales et on ne
propose pas la déchéance de nationalité
monsieur Castellani pour le suivant ah
il a disparu euh madame Martin pour le
689 alors bon c'est il y a il y a un
certain nombre d'arguments qui ont qui
ont été donnés moi j'ajouterai
simplement que cette affaire de
déchéance de nationalité
ne ne permet pas réparation et je pense
que c'est ainsi qu'on doit penser aussi
et que les magistrats d'ailleurs pensent
la question des sanctions et des peine
il faut que ça ait quelque chose qui a
un caractère de réparation ça n'est pas
le cas monsieur Valot pour le
879 monsieur monsieur VIIc pardon
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Solignac qui me
déconcentre oui monsieur le Président
également n nous souhaitons supprimer
cet article de BIS qui éant les cas de
d'échance de nationalité ce qui est déjà
une sanction extrêmement lourde mais
surtout il y a derrière cette article
l'idée générale que il faut lier la
question de l'immigration à celle de la
délinquence ou de la criminalité bien
entendu nous soutenons tout ce qui
concerne les mesures engagées dans la
lutte contre la criminalité quand elles
sont pertinentes légitimes argumenté
pesé lorsqu'elles s'inscrivent dans le
les le respect des droits des libertés
constitutionnel mais là il y a une
espèce d'affichage politique dirons-nous
autour de de de ce lien délinquence
criminalité immigration qui nous déplaît
fortement c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous souhaitons la suppression de cet
article madame
kerbidi madame fon merci monsieur le
Président je crois que c cet article
intégré au Sénat fait vraiment partie je
dirais des des des plus des plus honteux
ajouts que que le Sénat a pu formuler
sur ce texte et pourtant il y a le
choix après les droite et extrême droite
en fait après avoir tenté d'intégrer
dans dans le débat public l'idée qu'il y
aurait des Français de souche euh tant
ici euh d'intégrer maintenant le concept
d'étranger euh de souche c'est vraiment
une attaque sur nos principes
fondamentaux sur l'idée euh qui est un
principe important dans notre pays du du
droit du sol on est vraiment dans les
vieilles rangenes racistes xénophobes
euh avec sur des sur des propositions
qui ont été formulé dans le programme de
Jean-Marie Le Pen en en 2007 qui
malheureusement a été repris euh dans
les propositions du discours de Sarkozi
en 2010 et je dis encore plus
malheureusement sous l'air Hollande sous
sous d'autres formes je crois que
vraiment faut lutter de manière
importante contre ces amalgames et cette
suspicion qui sont faits les binationaux
au même titre que les étrangers ou les
ou les Français nés sur notre territoire
ne sont pas des suspects en puissance
monsieur
Mandon oui merci monsieur le Président
notre groupe démocrate considère que les
amendements portant sur le droit de la
nationalité euh sur cette partie de la
discussion du texte n'ont pas non
manifestement pas leur place dans le
projet de loi euh une telle réforme ne
peut-être abordée selon nous au détour
d'un d'un texte il s'agit d'un sujet à
traiter à part entière il faut savoir
d'ailleurs circonscrire aussi nos débats
parlementaires nous considérons tout
simplement qu'il s'agit là de de de
cavalier
législatif madame guevnou
oui monsieur le Président merci le
groupe Renaissance a déposé lui
également un amendement de suppression
pour comme vous l'avez dit Madame la
rapporteur et monsieur le Président pour
ce qui est un article qui est à
l'évidence un cavalier législatif et
pose en outre des questions de des
problèmes de
constitutionnalité madame la rapporteur
je présume votre amis favorable votre
amendement vous présumez bien monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre
moi aussi je je veux redire le fait que
ces articles qui concernent le code de
naalité enfin en fait le Code civil
puisque le code de la sociité s'est fu
le Code civil en 1993 par Pierre maignui
mais n'ont rien à faire dans dans ce
texte je l'ai redit au Sénat et le
président de la commission des lois
d'ailleurs la la la l'a accepté l'a
accepté lui-même au Sénat il n'avait pas
d'autre but c'était les contenus des
débats au Sénat pour la la droite
sénatoriale que de créer ce ce débat il
faut donc refermer à mon avis ces
dispositions qui sont à coup sûr
censurées par le Conseil constitutionnel
puisque ce que nous avons choisi c'est
un code des étranger et pas le Code
civil aucun texte d'ailleurs des
étrangers y compris lorsque la droite
était en responsabilité gouvernementale
n'a présenté en même temps le code de la
nationalité et le code des étrangers il
faut toujours distinguer les deux choses
à la demande du Conseil d'État c'est ici
vérifier ce qui veut pas dire que ici ou
là on ne peut pas vérifier effectivement
des modifications qui relèvent de la
nationalité mais qui n'ont rien à voir
dans dans dans ce texte je préciserai
d'ailleurs rapidement que sur le fond
par ailleurs cearticle de B A est
totalement inutile puisque il existe
déjà une déchéance de nationalité depuis
1996 les attentats que la France avait
connu qui avait été introduite par le
gouvernement de de Jacques Chirac qui
prévoit notamment que pour les actes de
terrorisme et les atteintes aux intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation comme les
actions au profit d'un État étranger on
pense évidemment à l'espionnage le
ministre de l'intérieur peut engager des
déché de nationalité contrôlé par le
Conseil d'État ce que je fais
lorsque'évidemment on atteint à l' viis
des policiers des gendarmes donc par
ailleurs
sur le fond si on devient discuter cet
article est super faitatoire mais je
veux dire que pour les autres articles
qui concernent le code de nationalité le
Code civil donc ce sera un avis de
report à un autre texte mais évidemment
négatif dans ce
texteci monsieur goustin oui quelques
mot monsieur le Président pour répondre
aux collègues et sur leurs accusations
en
suspicion d'être contre les étranger il
s'agit pas de suspicion là il s'agit
bien de les de ceux qui sont reconnus
coupables donc il y a un jugement ou un
arrêt donc on est très très loin de la
de la suspicion et puis simplement pour
souligner puisque certains ont regretté
que du temps de Hollande ces
préoccupations soient ressorties c'était
effectivement du temps où une gauche de
gouvernement existait et elle savait
être pleine de bon
sens
ménagerord merci monsieur le Président
comme l'avit dit à plusieurs reprises
Marine Le Pen nous assurerons nous
assumerons les les erreurs de nos
prédécesseurs et donc nous souhaitons
garder le caractère exceptionnel de de
la déchance de nationalité néanmoins je
suis assez surpris quand je lis l'exposé
des motifs de votre amendement monsieur
le Président puisque vous expliquez que
vous êtes contre cette déchance de
nationalité pour les personnes
binationales condamnées pour homicide ou
tentative d'homicide contre un policier
ou un gendarme car il s'agirait d'une
sanction particulièrement grave mais je
vous le dis quand on attente à la vie
d'un policier d'un gendarme d'une
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique c'est un acte particulièrement
grave qui doit être condamné de la
manière la plus ferme et je vois dans
l'écriture de votre amendement une
soumission de la macronie à la France
insoumise à l'extrême gauche à la pensée
mélanchoniste qui considère que la
police tue et qui perpétuellement sal
l'image de nos forces de l'ordre dans le
pays donc je suis particulièrement
choqué il est possible que cette
disposition soit bien entendu reconnue
comme un cavalier qu'elle soit déjà
satisfaite ça a été dit mais sur le fond
ça en don sur votre position vis-à-vis
des forces de
l'ordre monsieur madame
Martin
monsieur Lucas merci monsieur le
Président je je veux venir quand même en
soutien au président de la commission
des lois parce que les accusations du
rassemblement national sont
particulièrement ignobles ce n'est pas
parce qu'on rappelle les principes de
l'État de droit ce n'est pas parce qu'on
est attaché à la justice que on
détesterait la police les fonctionnaires
de police les gendarmes ou autres et
donc je veux et donc je veux dire ici
que je me réjouis que sur ce
sujet une digue républicaine soit
rétablie effectivement entre vous
malheureusement qui avait absorbé parmi
vous la droite radicalisée qui finira
par pouvoir être qualifié d'extrême
droite à un moment sans doute à la fin
de de ce texte mais je me réjouis qu'il
existe encore un certain nombre de digu
républicaines qui permettent d'éviter de
tomber dans le piège de la division et
de la haine qui est le le moteur le
projet principal du Front
national je mets au voix ces amendements
de suppression qui votent pour qui vote
contre
ils sont
adoptés article est donc supprimé les
deux amendements de Monsieur po tomb on
enchane avec le
1691 madame la rapporteur merci monsieur
le Président donc là on en arrive au
disposition qui concerne le droit du sol
et vous le savez ça ne figurait pas dans
le dans le texte
initial le Sénat les a introduites à la
fois en commission et en
séance alors moi j'ai en fait suis
désolé j'avais pas le sentiment je suis
désolé hein c'est pas que que je
souhaite absolument qu'on m'écoute hein
mais c'est c'est c'est juste pour
pouvoir être en capacité de parler je
vous remercie ces articles il portent
une remise en cause inédite de notre
droit du sol et ces implications sont
telles que je crois que sur toutes ces
questions ça mérite à d'avoir un débat
apaisé je et je m'en félicite que nous
puissions l'avoir ce soir le projet de
loi que que nous défendons pour
contrôler l'immigration améliorer
l'intégration ça n'est pas le véhicule
législatif adéquate et ces articles me
semblent tout à fait
cavaliers en plus sur le fond le débat
en plus s'impose à nous hein il
conditionnerait la nationalisation par
le droit du sol à une manifestation
effective des des enfants étranger né en
France il introduirait une complexité et
une incertitude majeur pour ces jeunes
la nécessité de manifester activement sa
volonté pourrait créer en plus des
obstacles administratifs nouveaux des
situations d'incompréhension pour ceux
qui n'auraient pas pleinement conscience
à ce moment-là de cette exence et de ses
implications et il me semble aussi que
cet article de BIS contrevient par
ailleurs à l'objectif d'intégration des
enfants qui sont nés sur le territoire
qui fait pourtant l'honneur de notre
modèle républicain je vous
remercie
le suivant donc c'est le mien que je
défends le 628 je crois qu'il n'a pas de
défenseur le 708 madame
Martin on peut peut-être raisonner un
peu différemment et se demander ce qui
différencie un garçon par exemple qui a
14 ou 15 ans qui est né en France et un
autre garçon qui a 14 ou 15 ans et dont
les parents se sont installés en France
il y a quelques années qu'est-ce qui les
différencie bah rien du tout en fait
pourquoi parce que la République
reconnaît chacun comme ses enfants et ce
qui en est la marque c'est qu'ils sont à
égalité des droits et c'est que l'un
comme l'autre ces deux garçons ont
l'ensemble des mêmes droits et en
théorie bon bien sûr ça dépend qui
dirige le pays mais et qu' théorie ils
ont effectivement la possibilité d'être
traités de la même manière bon donc à
partir de là nous ne voyons pas
l'intérêt de dégrader encore cette
affaire qui est liée qui est lié au
droit du
sol c'est faux monsieur Valot non alors
c'est Monsieur
stolignac c'est mameame oui merci
monsieur le Président en fait évidemment
nous demandons la suppression de C
article nous saluons d'ailleurs une
forme d'unanimité quand même sur les
bans les bancs républicains pour
s'opposer à cette disposition qui vient
dégrader un dispositif d'automaticité du
droit du
sol et qui n'est finalement conforté par
aucun motif puissant qui nous permette
d'y réfléchir plus sérieusement c'est en
outre un cavalier législatif et nous
considérons que nous devons procéder à
la suppression de cette disposition qui
n'a rien à faire dans cette article dans
cette dans ce texte de
loi
le 1062 qu'est-ce madame
rol merci tout a été dit par mes
précédents précédentes collègues plutôt
qu' s'agisse de l'inégalité que ça crée
entre des personnes qui seraient
informées et des personnes qui ne le
sauraient pas de la difficulté d'arriver
à informer un jeune public et du danger
que ça porte et j'espère que N ouver là
encore face à ces amendements qui ne
enfin pardon face à ces articles issus
du Sénat qui ne devrait pas figurer dans
ce texte j'espère que là encore nous
pourrons trouver comme dans les articles
suivants une forte unanimité pour les
remettre à leur place c'est-à-dire en
dehors de ce
texte le suivant c'est Madame
kbidi merci monsieur le Président
au-delà de l'esprit même de cet article
on est est passé d'un droit qui
s'acquier à un droit qui se mérite à un
droit qui désormais se demande on voit
qu'il est enfermé dans des délais qui
sont extrêmement bref entre 16 ans et 18
ans attend à cet âge-là ne serait-ce que
toute la connaissance nécessaire de
notre droit euh a-t-on
également toutes les les clés pour bien
appréhender ce que cela représente en
réalité si on voulait supprimer le droit
du sol on s'y prendrait pas mieux donc
effectivement nous sommes pour la
suppression de cette article et nous
soutenons tout ce qui a été pr
précédemment dit par les
collègues c'est bien madame brocard
monsieur Monon oui monsieur le Président
mais je veux peux que vous redire notre
position à l'égard de d'une telle
disposition un article qui mérite
effectivement d'être supprimé nous
pensons qu'il faut pas conviendrait de
pas polluer le le
débat et s'apesantir sur sur un sujet
qui n'a pas sa place dans ce
texte et enfin Madame guevennou oui
merci monsieur le Président les groupe
Renaissance s'oppose sur la femme sur
cette à cet article qui est cavalier
mais au-delà sur le fond le groupe
Renaissance s'y oppose aussi parce que
cet article de BIS introduirait une
complexité des
incertitudes pour les jeunes étrangers
qui sont nés en France avec la nécessité
de manifester activement leur volonté
cela pourrait créer des obstacles
administratifs des situations
d'incompréhension pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas pleinement conscience de
cette cette exigence et on considère que
ça la nuirait à l'objectif d'intégration
de ces enfants nés sur le
territoire madame la rapporteur je
présume votre avis favorable présumez
bien monsieurésid monsieur le ministre
même avis monsieur
léoman merci monsieur le président
c'estel quel chose qui m'étonne toujours
beaucoup pour des gens qui disent aimer
notre pays je ne comprends pas pourquoi
si réellement on aime notre pays on ne
souhaite pas que des gens
qui sont étrangers deviennent
français vraiment c'est quelque chose
d'étonnant pour moi je veux
dire le fait que des gens acquièrent
notre nationalité fait grandir notre
peuple et d'ailleurs le rassemblement
national lors du débat sur la réforme
des retraite nous disait il faut faire
des enfants il faut faire des enfants
comme ça ça va financer le système de
retraite et là quand il s'agit d'enfants
qui deviendrait français mais qui sont
étrangers ils ont un problème avec ça
d'où vient cette incohérence et bien
cette incohérence vient d'un truc qui
s'appelle la xénophobie c'est-à-dire la
peur des étrangers souvent le
rassemblement national nous dit vous
dites que nous sommes racistes mais vous
êtes incapable de le prouver là vous en
avez fait la démonstration
madamemeilleur
m non vous vouliez pas causer monsieur
gilet oui sur le droit du sol je vous
rappelle la position du rassemblement
national nous souhaitons la suppression
du droit du sol comme 74 % des Français
d'ailleurs parce que quand vous voyez un
certain nombre de délinquants de casseur
qui attaqueent la police des gens qui ne
respectent pas les lois de la République
que devrionsnous faire leur accorder la
nationalité française certainement pas
le fait d'être né en France ne doit pas
donner automatiquement la nationalité
française être français ça s'hérite ou
ça se
mérite alors peut-être une remarque
parce que est-ce que ce sont les mêmes
sondages de la réalité parallèle qui
vous a fait lire l'exposé de mon
amendement tout à l'heure parce que je
relis l'exposé de l'amendement que vous
m'avez accusé de de de de rapportter à
l'infraction en cause outre le fait
qu'il s'agit d'une sension d'une
particulière gravité voyez que vous avez
un prisme particulier pour les réalités
comme pour les sondages que vous maniez
avec une absence totale de parsonie
Madame
Ménard merci monsieur le Président il y
a de nombreux enfants étrangers nés en
France ont le désir sincère de devenir
français un/art des 110000 étrangers qui
deviennent français chaque année sont
nés en France de parents étrangers alors
avec cet article il me semble qu'il
n'est pas du tout question d'empêcher
l'octroit de notre nationalité mais
seulement soucier de la façon dont elle
est transmise acquise et reçu et donc
moi j'insiste parce que avec cet article
l'acquisition de la nationalité
française va être soumise à une
manifestation de volonté et ça me semble
un un minimum pour pour l'unité de la
France et pour pour ce bien précieux qui
est notre nationalité qui ne faut
évidemment pas brader je vous remercie
oui je crois qu'il y a aucun problème
effectivement à accueillir dans la
nationalité et la citoyenneté parce qu'à
18 ans c'est bien la même chose euh
aucun problème à accueillir un nombre
important d'étrangers qui se sont
établis ou qui sont nés en France qui
ont résidé mais je ne vois pas en quoi
euh établir un acte de volonté vouloir
être français serait antidémocratique je
rappelle qu'un certain nombre d'États en
Europe comme d'ailleurs outre atlantique
qui sont pas moins démocraties que le
nôtre appliquent des règles différentes
en ce qui concerne le droit de la
nationalité à la naissance ou en cours
de vie donc ce ce ce cette verdict
définitif de de xénophobie de
racisme ne suffit pas à faire une vérité
même quand on la répète à l'envie je
crois que d'être français c'est un
honneur que de le demander n'est pas un
desonneur c'est un acte de volonté la
nation est grande quand elle sait
accueillir mais la nation est grande
quand elle sait aussi accueillir des
gens qui veulent réellement appartenir à
cette nation et enfin Monsieur Lucas
merci monsieur le Président collègue du
rassemblement national a permis de
démontrer avec Briot ce qu'a exposé
notre collègue léomand sur le racisme et
la xénophobie qui sont celles du du
Front national quand vous dites être
français ça séite tout ça se mérite
d'abord on comprend qu'avec vous pas
grand monde le mérite quand on lit les
amendements et qu'on vous entend depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant depuis
plusieurs années mais surtout en fait
vous vous ne la méritez pas la France
vous vous ne la méritez pas parce que
vous ne l'aimez pas parce que vous la
voyez frileuse repliée sur elle-même
fermée aux autres
béliqueuse divisé entre elles la France
c'est une belle devise Liberté Égalité
Fraternité vous ne la méritez pas quand
vous demandez à des enfants entre 16 et
18 ans de choisir entre 16 et 18 ans
peut-être en conflit affectif avec ses
parents on peut faire on peut faire
et et vous décidez de fermer une porte
après 18 ans pour des des gens qui ont
envie de devenir français de contribuer
à faire de nous une nation bien plus
forte que ce que vous voulez en faire et
que ce que vous en dites madame
kbid merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais revenir à des arguments
peut-être plus juridiques je ferai un
parallèle avec par exemple les actions
pour concernant laaffiliation si on veut
décider de savoir de quel père de quelle
mère on vient ça fait partie de la
construction de son identité au même
titre peut-être que la nationalité et
ben on a jusqu'à 28 ans pour le faire
c'est 10 ans à comptter de la de sa
majorité là on demande à des jeunes
presque à des enfants de décider entre
16 et 18 ans s'ils veulent être ou ne
pas être français et donc effectivement
je trouve que ce délai il est
particulièrement court et il ne permet
absolument pas une décision éclairée
quand on décide de savoir quel père ou
quelle mère on veut avoir on a jusqu'à
28 ans là l'article non seulement il est
fondé sur de mauvaise raisons il est
dicté par une idéologie qui nous dépasse
c'est que l'on combat mais en plus
juridiquement il est complètement
aberrent on va pouvoir voter qui vare
pour les amendement de
suppression voilà qui vote contre ils
sont adoptés ils font tomber les autres
amendements à l'article et il supprime
l'article le 2 ter a on a un amendement
de suppression également de Madame la
rapporteur le
1692 euh oui merci monsieur le président
donc en fait cet article il vient durcir
euh les modalités d'accès à la
nationalité par mariage il s'agit d'une
disposition qui ne figurit pas dans le
texte initial et que le Sénat a
introduit en séance publique et j'y suis
défavorable pour les mêmes raisons que
celles qui motié la suppression de
l'article de BIS je vous
remercie le le 185 monsieur Lucas oui je
souscris à à la volonté de suppression
exprimée par Madame la rapporteur donc
défendu monsieur le Président le 713
qu'est-ce qu' défend monsieur Loman
oui là il s'agit de l'acquisition de la
nationalité par
l'amour là encore c'est une histoire
profondément républicaine que celle-ci
depuis 1793 et la constitution de la
Première République un citoyen peut
devenir enfin un étranger peut devenir
français dès lors que il épouse
quelqu'un qui porte notre nationalité
voyez-vous finalement nous sommes ceux
qui défend d'une tradition républicaine
celle du droit du sol celle de la
possibilité de devenir français quand on
s'aime et je dois dire que vraiment ce
débat révèle une fracture qui existe en
entre deux visions de la France et je
parle bien de la France parce que de
visions de la République il n'y en a
qu'une la vision de la République c'est
celle du droit du sol et c'est celle de
la capacité à devenir Français justement
par ses liens affectifs et amoureux le
rassemblement national et
malheureusement les républicains qui
portent mal leur nom sont sortis de
cette logique-el ils ne défendent donc
pas des logiques républicaines mais des
logiques xénophobes je suis désolé je le
répète une nouvelle fois c'est ça dont
il s'agit
désormais le suivant c'est le groupe
socialiste qui le défend
madametermeilleur ouis ben écoutez il
sera défendu parce qu'on se range aux
mêmes arguments et on est évidemment
hostile à cet allongement de la durée de
la de des délais de mariage et de
communauté de vie pour l'accès à la
nationalité par le mariage madame
fossillon oui on supprime jeouvre le
micro c'est bon non ben évidemment on
s'oppose à à à cet article qui vise à
durcir les conditions d'accès à la
nationalité par le mariage j'en profite
pour dire que déjà les délais sur la
naturalisation sont vraiment aujourd'hui
très anormalement longs que en en 5 an
il y a plus de 5000 personnes qu' ont
saisi le Défenseur des droits suite à
des difficultés d'accès au services
public de de nature naturalisation et
que moi je vois dans mon département
aujourd'hui combien les délais d'attente
ont augmenté juste pour que le dossier
commence à être instruit il y a des gens
qui depuis 2 ans voient
sur le site la plateforme de dépôt le
fait que depuis 2 ans leur dossier est
toujours en attente on peut pas avoir un
service public qui fonctionne avec des
délais aussi
longs le madame recard pour le suivant
monsieur Mandon oui monsieur le
Président Ben même traitement nous
préconisons demandons la suppression de
l'article qui n'a pas sa place selon
nous dans ce
texte madame givenous le
suivant et j'en également un amendement
qui est défendu madame la rapporteur
votre avis est favorable je présume à
nouveau donc je met au voix les
amendements al c'est Madame B qui veut
parler oui rapidement monsieur le
président alors on a bien compris euh
quelle était la société dans laquelle
vous vouliez que nous évoluions dans les
dans les mois et dans les années à venir
c'est une société où il n'y a plus de
frontières où les gens font ce qu'ils
veulent où c'est open bar surtout où
effectivement maintenant euh on
acquierre la nationalité française très
rapidement et pourquoi pas effectivement
voter un amendement qui supprimerait
tout délai pour acquérir la nationalité
française allons-y puisque nous sommes
sur cette lancée vive viv cette nouvelle
société que vous nous promettez alors ça
n'est pas obéir à une logique xénophobe
comme vous vous plaisez à le dire et à
le redire que de prétendre que la
nationalité française se mérite elle n'a
pas à être dévaluer ni dévaloriser et
vous ne faites que dévaloriser et
dévaluer la nationalité française qui
manifestement pour vous ne représente
absolument rien je suis désolé de vous
dire que l'arc républicain que nous nous
représentons effectivement peut vous
paraître totalement désué mais cet arc
républicain effectivement est très
attaché à la nationalité française et
que ça vous plaise ou non nous
continuerons à défendre la nationalité
française euh monsieur
léomand c'est quand même incroyable en
réalité parce que vous nous dites C des
et la République écoutez je viens de
vous parler de la première fois qu'elle
a existé dans notre pays en
179293 et en vous rappelant règles alors
on peut pas faire plus ancien que ça vu
que c'est la première fois que ça
existait c'est nous qui défendons la
République des ettes c'est nous qui qui
défendons la République du drapeau
tricolore de La Marseillaise et de la
devise Liberté Égalité Fraternité et je
suis assez content du fait qu'il y ait
encore des digues républicaines qui
existent entre ceux qui défendent cette
vision de la France avec le droit du sol
et l'acquisition de la nationalité
française sur cette base et vous qui
défendez une politique xénoph sur le
sujet je suis désolé de vous le rappeler
enfin sur la question des frontières
enfin jamais nous n'avons dit que nous
ne voulions pas de frontières au
contraire nous sommes ceux qui propose
un protectionnisme solidaire mais nous
souhaitons contrôler davantage les
marchandises et les capitaux et que on
accueille plus dignement les gens qui
arrivent dans notre pays madame
rugol oui c'est c'est compliqué de pas
réagir à à de tels propos comme si
toutes les personnes qui ne reprenaient
pas la phraséologie et la mythologie de
l'extrême droite de venez des
anti-France c'est un peu pénible parce
que surtout la France elle est faite de
ses diversités elle est faite de ses
accents de ses langues régionales de ces
territoires qui n'ont rien à voir les
uns avec les autres et elle est faite de
toutes les vagues d'immigration qui la
composent et qu'en fait cette
france-l c'est la vraie France que vous
détestez vous voulez une vision
normalisante normée de ce qui est la
représentation d'être française ou
français là où le pays entier vous
renvoie l'inverse là où les grandes
heures de notre pays ont été les heures
où nous avons accueilli le plus de monde
parce que un pays qui est grand un pays
qui est sûr un pays qu'on aime c'est un
pays qui n'a pas peur d'avoir d'être
contaminé par d'autres parce qu'au
contraire sa culture s'étend à d'autres
le français j'en suis Fiè j'ai envie que
beaucoup de gens le parlent j'ai
l'impression que vous vous avez envie de
garder cette langue cette culture et ce
pays uniquement pour vous entre vos
quatre murs de votre petit parti et ça
commence à bien faire madame
kirbid je voulais juste rajouter un mot
par rapport à tout ce qui a été dit par
mes collègues mais en tant que en tant
qu'ultramarine dont le nom est à forte
consonance bretonne mais euh avec avec
du sang d'esclave je veux dire qu'il y a
pas une conception du français il y a
pas des Français de souche il y a pas
des Français historiquement français on
pourrait faire des prises de sang à tout
le monde ici je suis pas sûr que
beaucoup auraient la nationalité euh il
y a une conception du droit
de la nationalité et cette conception
nous estimons aujourd'hui que le le
droit de la nationalité française est
suffisamment contraignant que les règles
ne permettent absolument pas de donner
la nationalité à tout le monde et dans
des délais extrêmement brefs et nous ne
voulons pas que ce droit soit
considérablement alourdi pour ceux qui
font la démarche et qui veulent devenir
français donc non non nous ne sommes pas
absolument pas pour un monde sans
frontièr le monde dans lequel nous
vivons est difficile nous en sommes
conscients nous sommes tout à fait en
phase avec la réalité du monde dans
lequel nous vivons mais nous ne sommes
absolument pas d'accord avec le monde
que vous vous souhaitez monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président non juste pour dire au
rassemblement national à Madame bord qui
qui est intervenu je sais pas de quoi
vous avez parler mais en tout cas pas du
texte de loi puisque le texte de loi il
il vise à travailler sur le code des
étrangers et que les dispositions qui
ont été rajoutées par le Sénat
indépendamment du fait que ce soit des
cavaliers législatifs ce qui nous permet
quand même de dire aux français quand on
est honnête que ces dispositions ne
seront pas retenues quoi qu'on en pense
par le Conseil constitutionnel donc
c'est peut-être pas la peine enfin je
crois d'en passer quelques heures on l'a
déjà dit au Sénat d'ailleurs ça a été
retenu par quelqu'un de vre groupe qui a
évoqué le fait que c'était très
certainement des cavaliers législatifs
ne vise pas à restreindre à restreindre
le le le les les restrictions pardon de
cette totologie de la
nationalité c'était des des dispositions
du Sénat qui venaient justement
alourdir le l'accès à cette nationalité
et le fait de supprimer cet article ne
veut pas dire qu'on recule par rapport
au droits existants ça veut dire qu'on
revient au droits existants donc il
s'agit pas à personne personne personne
ne veut enfin je crois en tout cas et
surtout pas du côté du gouvernement ou
de la majorité si je peux parler en son
nom alléger des des dispositifs c'est
nous madame la députée qui avons permis
de faire des entretiens d'assimination
qui aujourd'hui se concrétisent par - 30
à - 40 % de naturalisation par rapport à
ce que faisait le président Sar et le
président Hollande donc faites pas ces
faux près ce que nous faisons ici c'est
le code des étrangers et confondre le
code des étrangers avec le code civil de
la nationalité confondre l'étranger avec
le National c'est créer la confusion que
nous voulons éviter puisque tous les
textes depuis que la République existe
distingue le code des étrangers du Code
civil donc quand on supprime les
articles on ne fait rien d'autre que
revenir au droit existants on ne recule
pas dans ce droit quel que soit ce qu'on
pense donc peut-être que votre
intervention euh voulez viser euh les
les les rangs de la nupes
eu peut-être voilà donc ça c'est un
débat que vous entre vous mais je pense
qu'il est ici vraiment avenue puisqu'on
parle pas de ce sujet-là dans ce texte
et s'il s'agit du texte gouvernemental
là vous faites une grave erreur puce
qu'onevient juste au droit classique et
moi je je pense qu'on a tous vu monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
bien sûr les parlementaires sont tout à
fait libres de leur discussion mais je
l'avais déjà dit au au Sénat c'est déjà
assez compliqué le code des étrangers il
y a déjà assez de dispositions qui vont
créer des difficultés des nuances et des
sujets qui vont me semble-t-il avoir des
discussions fortes pour pouvoir en
rajouter d'autres viendra le moment où
sur une proposition de loi ou sur un
texte gouvernemental on parlera
peut-être de la nationalité mais on va
peut-être déjà se concentrer sur un
sujet complexe le code des
étrangers non je mets au voix il y a
madame car qui s je mets au voix les
amendements de suppression qui V
pour qui vote
contre ils sont adoptés alors on va
avoir le débat
après le de TRB amendement 1693 de
Madame la
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
là encore he c'est un article qui est
relatif au au droit du sol qui a été
ajouté par le Sénat en séance public
alors comme le reste des
articlesabordant le sujet c'est une
remise en cause inédite de notre droit
du sol hein et en plus ça manque de
clarté de précision et les termes je
cite assimilation manifeste à ce stade
ils sont vagues subjectifs et ainsi que
l'affaire marqué je me permets de la
citer de nouveau hein la Défenseur des
droits au cours de son audition cette
rédaction pourrait contrevenir à
l'objectif de valeur constitutionnelle
d'accessibilité et d'intelligibilité de
la loi et plus symboliquement sa
disposition représente aussi une entrave
ça a été dit déjà à l'intégration des
jeunes étrangers nés en
France je défends mon amendement mais le
631 n'a pas de défenseur dans la salle
ah
si
monsur vous nêtes pas signur monsieurint
le 714 madame torignia merci monsieur le
Président bon effectivement nous on veut
supprimer aussi cet amendement on a déjà
eu l'occasion
de de discuter de ces deux termes
intégration assimilation moi je veux
rappeler que le terme
assimilation oblige donc l'étranger qui
qui qui doit être assimilé à abandonner
complètement sa culture et on a là donc
la vision de de de la droite et je pense
que l'extrême droite s'y complet aussi
puisque tout à l'heure ils ont défendu
ce terme c'est une vision colonialiste
raciste et xénophobe il y a pas
d'autrees mots je suis désolée il y a
pas d'autrees mots donc on on veut
supprimer cet article parce que nous
pensons que on peut faire République et
on peut faire nation avec toutes nos
diff et avec toutes les
cultures le 882 qu'est-ce qui le
défend chez les socialistes qui défend
le 882 défendu
Ouiame car oui oui merci monsieur le
Président effectivement comme
précédemment exprimé ici cet article
nous souhaitons le voir supprimer tout
simplement parce
que effectivement la perte du droit du
sol en cas de il faut d'assimilation
l'assimilation effectivement ça n'a
jamais été le terme que dans notre pays
nous avons défendu moi je je je peux en
parler même personnellement et je crois
que l'intégration toujours a été
l'élément essentiel pour pouvoir
finalement permettre aux personnes qui
viennent d'autres pays et qui ont choisi
de vivre ici étudier se marier fonder
une famille travailler effectivement
c'est l'intégration l'élément essentiel
et pas forcément l'assimulation donc on
est
contre le suivant monsieur
merci monsieur le Président au-delà de
ce qu'on dit mes collègues et auquel je
souscris et propos auquel je souscris
évidemment pour supprimer cet article
l'expression manifestement pas assimilée
à la Communauté française est un une
expression intéressante à analyser
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire et qui
détermine ce qui être assimilé à la
Communauté française je l'ai dit ce
matin désolé pour ceux qui étaient là
mais moi qui mange et du très bon fois
gras de chez Monsieur Valot dans l'lande
et to babine de ma grand-mère par
alliance qui mange donc un plat Kaby et
un plat Landis dans la même journée
quand j'ai de la chance est est-ce que
je suis pour le rassemblement national
convenablement assimilé j'ai cité Michel
Sardou tout à l'heure j'aurais pu citer
raled est-ce que je suis quand j'écoute
de la musique bien assimilé à la
Communauté française j'essaie de
démontrer chers collègues ne vous
énervez pas il me reste 10 secondes
j'essaie de démontrer par l'absurde que
ce concept d'assimilation à la
Communauté française à la culture
française que tout ça est vraiment
ridicule hein j'aimerais qu'on aille
voir vous comment vous vivez et si vous
êtes vraiment bien assimilé à la culture
française que vous prétendez défendre
dev com le
1166 madame
kbidi et au-delà de tous les arguments
qui ont déjà été développés je pense que
le plus le plus important c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être la le problème
de la sécurité juridique on est là sur
un concept qui n'a aucun ancrage et qui
mettrait nos administrations dans des
situations extrêmement compliquées et je
ne suis pas d'ailleurs certaine que
cette article en l'état puisse passer le
fil de la constitutionnalité donc bien
évidemment nous soutenons la suppression
madame rard ou monsieur Mandon
oui juste quelques mots pour dire que
évidemment nous sommes pour la
suppression de l'article puisque nous
considérons qu'il n'a manifestement pas
sa place comme pour comme les autres
précédemment j'ai pu évoquer tout à
l'heure et évidemment sur cette
parenthèse que certains voudrai ouvrir à
propos de l'assimilation je crois que on
perd son
parce que c'est pas ici le le sujet du
du texte sur lequel nous devons nous
concentrer le 1554 madame gevnou oui
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
pour les mêmes raisons que précédemment
et parce que donc cet article est un
cavalier législatif nous souhaitons sa
suppression
merci alors madame la rapporteur
j'imagine votre avis favorable monsieur
Guiton
oui merci monsieur le le président donc
finalement depuis tout à l'heure en fait
on voit très bien que nous avons AFF
faaire à un texte qui est très très mou
qui nous vient du Sénat et en plus
lorsque le Sénat propose tout simplement
de dire d'ajouter l'étranger perd le
droit donc de devenir français s'il
n'est pas assimilé la communaité
française vous êtes tous alliés main
dans la main pour rejeter ce truc mais
c'est c'est quand même hallucinant de
voir qu'aujourd'hui dans notre assemblée
on n'est même pas capable de dire que
OUI pour devenir français il faut être
assimilé à la Communauté française
excusez-moi du peu finalement on est
dans on est dans sur le même débat
qu'hier hier on voulait durcir les
conditions d'obtention du droit du sol
du regroupement familial aujourd'hui du
droit du sol mais à chaque fois en fait
le débat il n'est pas là il faut
supprimer le droit du sol il faut
supprimer le regroupement familial et
c'est ce que nous proposons nous et
c'est ce que nous voulons faire au
rassemblement national parce que
pourquoi nous avons aujourd'hui des
individus qui sont devenus Français qui
ne respectent pas ni la Communauté
française et donc j'aimerais quand même
paraphraser ce ces termes lorsque
certains individu vont devenir français
on voit aujourd'hui que certains jeunes
étrangers est arrivé à l'âge adulte
constitue une génération qui pour
paraphraser max Gallot sont physiquement
d'ici incontestablebl d'ici mais dont
l'âme est malheureusement d'ailleurs et
c'est bien pour cellà que nous avons des
individus qui sont devenus Français qui
ne respecteront jamais les valeurs ni de
la République ni de la France parce
qu'ils sont devenus Français alors
Monsieur monsieur
léomand
bon je je on arrive exactement dans ce
qu'on pouvait attendre le rassemblement
national se dévoile petit à petit et
montre qu'il ne connaît ni notre pays ni
ce qui'est l'histoire même de notre
drapeau notre drapeau lui-même est né
d'une grève antiraciste de marin breton
qui ont refusé en 1790 de se rendre en
Haïti pour aller matterer des révoltes
d'esclaves et qui qui se rebellaient
contre l'esclavage au nom de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen et ces marins bretons parlent
aussi du drapeau blanc qui était sur les
navires qui étaient le leur cette
histoire a fait tellement de bruit
qu'elle a fini par arriver à l'Assemblée
national et c'est mIRABO qui défendant
le drapeau tricolore dit il est temps de
remplacer le drapeau qui est celui de de
la gloire par la guerre par celui qui
sera celui de la sainte confraternité
entre les peuples des amis de la liberté
sur toute la terre et la terreur des
conspirateurs et des tyrans l'Assemblée
nationale le 21 septembre 1790 décide
pour la première fois de faire du
drapeau rouge blanc bleu à l'époque le
drapeau des navires français voyez-vous
l'histoire de la France elle-même de
notre drapeau que vous dites tant chérir
mais que vous ne connaissez pas c'est
l'histoire d'une grève antiraciste
avalez-vousle c'est l'histoire de la
France mon
ouais notre collègue du rassemblement
national dit les gens sont ici mais leur
â est ailleurs alors écoutezv je ne sais
pas où est votre â ni même si vous en
avez une mais je sais que vos sous sont
chez Monsieur Poutin qui vous finance
abondamment les campagnes électorales
que les ballerines de Madame Le Pen
quand elle danse avec un néonazis sont
avienne et que vos fondateurs éta
àmingen bien on va pouvoir voter les
amendements de suppression qui vote pour
les amendements de
suppression qui vote contre ils sont
adoptés
le 2 TERC l'amendement
1694 pardon merci monsieur le
Président alors s'il vous plaît chers
collègues en fait je vais je propose la
suppression de cet article le but c'est
de le replacer plus tard dans le titre
consacré à l'outreem je vous
remercie alors attendez parce qu'on a
d'autres am suppression madame
Martin je m'autorise quand même juste
une petite remarque quand on entend tout
ce qui a été dit cela vient en écho à ce
qui a été dit par le ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur Darmanin lorsqu'il
disait que Madame Le Pen était molle en
matière d'immigration donc vous voyez un
peu où on en est non là nous demandons
la suppression de cet amendement dans la
mesure où nous ne sommes pas d'accord
avec cet écart et donc qui amènerait une
dérogation au droit du sol à la guillane
et à Saint-Martin n nous considérons
encore une fois que la République
reconnaît tous ses enfants ce qui fait
valoir le droit du sol sur l'ensemble du
territoire français quel qu'il
soit monsieur Val
883 cet
amendement cet amendement donc de notre
groupe vise à supprimer cet
article qui renforce les conditions quis
de la nationalité pour les mineurs
étrangers nés dans certains territoires
ultramarins de parents étrangers ces
dispositions visent à s'appliquer à
Saint-Martin à Saint-Martin le régime
juridique d'acquisition de la
nationalité actuellement en vigueur à
Mayotte ne pourrait se voir appliquer
les dispositions de l'article 217
acquisition de la nationalité à la
majorité ou par réclamation anticipée
pour les mineurs étrangers nés de par
étrang en France que les mineurs dont un
des parents au moins était à la date de
leur naissance en situation régulière
ininterrompu sur le territoire français
plus de 3 mois cet article souhaite donc
porter atteinte au droit du sol il n'a
pas sa place dans cette loi consacrée à
l'immigration et nous considérons donc
qu'il faut supprimer cet
article
alors madame F madame carbid défendu euh
madame brocard monsieur Mandon
défendu alors euh madame la rapporteur
votre avis est favorable pour les
raisons que vous avez exposé monsieur le
ministre non mais dire comme Madame la
rapporteur queon en reparlera sans doute
lors du volet euh
outreemire que porte le rapporteur
Olivier Sava donc je souscris à la
suppression pour remettre ses
dispositions en fin de
texte alors Monsieur néelen Merci
monsieur le Président B on comprend la
la nécessité de de supprimer pour le
redécaler au titre 6 néanmoins étant
donné que l'amendement de ma collègue
Estelle Youssoufa risque de de tomber il
était important de prendre la parole sur
sur le sujet parce que c'est un article
qui est essentiel pour Mayotte il durcit
les conditions du droit du sol à Mayotte
actuellement l'enfant n étranger de
parents étrangers ne peut prétendre au
droit du sol que si au moins un un de
ses parents vivaient régulièrement
depuis 3 mois à Mayotte l'article 2 TERC
porte ce délai de 3 mois à 1 an c'est
une réelle demande de la part de de la
part d''estell et et des députés des
députés maoret donc c'est pour ça que
nous déposerons un un amendement le CL
1725 de notre rapporteur Olivier serva
et j'espère que nous pourrons avoir un
avis positif sur sur ce sujet monsieur
Gouffier
oui pour dire monsieur le Président que
le groupe Renaissance suivra
euh la rapporteur sur cette demande de
suppression en étant très attentif
effectivement euh à l'amendement qui
sera présenté par le groupe lot sur
Mayot et qui viendra plus
tard bon alors on va mettre au voix les
amendements de suppression qui votent
pour qui vote contre ils sont adoptés
ils font tomber les amendements suivants
ils suppriment l'article le 1697 pour
l'article 2 ter madame la rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président les deux
articles hein de bis et deux terres sont
liés le de TER rend impossible la
naturalisation des mineurs nés en France
et fait l'objet d'une condamnation pour
des infractions graves ou ayant fait
l'objet d'un arrêté d'expulsion d'une
interdiction de territoire avant leur
majorité je suis défavorable à cet
article pour les mêmes raisons la remise
en cause du droit du sol et sur le fond
sur l'intégration des enfants je vous
remercie et bien vous avez brillamment
exposé cet amendement que j'ai identique
avec vous alors le mien est défendu le
719 monsieur sintou sur le sur le
719 euh nous souhaitons
réaffirmer que pour nous ce qui compte
et ce qui est indépassable c'est le
droit du sol tout à l'heure d'cun ont
dit que la nationalité française se
méritait je ne vois pas encore une fois
quelle est la différence entre quelqu'un
qui est né en France de parents français
par rapport à d'autres situations nos
droits ne doivent pas être différents
nous devons et nous sommes normalement
traité traité de la même manière ce
d'autant plus que
lorsque l'on remonte d'une génération et
que l'on regarde la situation des
grands-parents d'un/ers des Français
un/ers des Français sont dans une
situation où au moins l'un de leurs
grands-parents n'est pas né en France
donc il faudrait regarder quels seraient
les conséquen de ce type de disposition
si l'on remontait d'une génération voir
quelles seraient les conséquences sur
l'Assemblée nationale et j'imagine que
finalement nous ne serions plus si
nombreux que que cela très trêve de
plaisanterie encore une fois pour nous
un enfant né ici est un enfant França le
884 qui les socialistes le
défendu le
1167 madame F
oui très très rapidement pour pour dire
à quel point en fait cet article vise
encore à stigmatiser les personnes né N
étrangère et et cherche vraiment à
amalgamer délinquence et et étranger
parce qu'on sait très bien qu'en fait
les le nombre de personnes visées par
cet article est absolument
dérisoire vraiment dérisoire et qu'en
réalité le but c'est uniquement de
pouvoir faire ce lien-là et par là même
de pouvoir remettre en cause le le droit
du sol qui est un principe pourtant euh
vieux de plusieurs siècles euh sur notre
pays même avant la République et que
beaucoup ici souvent se prétendent de
l'histoire française pensent être celles
et ceux qui la défendaient mais
chercheent toujours en tout cas à en
extirper uniquement la partie qui qui
les arrange pour défendre un projet
d'exclusion alors même que le droit du
sol est un principe qui anime notre
nation depuis 1515 monsieur Mandon le
suivant
défendu madame gevenou le 1555
oui merci monsieur le président euh un
amendement de suppression de cet article
mais qui ne signifie pas pour autant que
nous sommes pas attentifs avec le groupe
R naissance aux questions posées sur les
territoires ultramarins et on y sera
particulièrement vigilant au titre
6 alors madame la rapporteur votre avis
est favorable monsieur
bobri merci monsieur le Président
l'acquisition de la nationalité
française ne peut être offerte à ceux
qui même mineurs ont fait le choix de ne
pas respecter nos lois républicaines
ceux qu'on appelle français aujourd'hui
car l'accès à notre nationalité a été
bradé sont sur représenté dans la
commission de CRIM et délit dans notre
pays c'est un fait alors jusqu'à quand
jusqu'à quand les Français vont payer
par le sang cette immigration que vous
leur imposez jusqu'à quand allons-nous
offrir l'hospitalité à ceux qui bafouent
nos lois et qui malgré tout peuvent se
voir offrir la nationalité française
jusqu'à quand comptez-vous faire de ces
individus des Français alors qu'ils ont
clairement démontré qu'ils n'ont aucun
respect pour notre pays faut être clair
avec les étrangers ne comptez
certainement pas devenir français si
vous avez décidé de piétiner nos lois et
si l'extrême gauche trouve à redire sur
ce principe c'est certainement par souci
électoraliste ne pouvant pour le moment
s'assurer les voix du Hamas dans notre
pays il s'assure la voix les voix des
délinquants qui le chérissent dans les
quartiers Monsieur
saintoule Merci monsieur le
Président on évoque la question du du
droit du sol et j'aimerais redire encore
une fois à quel point ce principe est
d'une beauté splendide en réalité parce
qu'il postule que selon ce que le mot de
jean-genen que la République est un
grand acte de confiance et d'audace et
effectivement c'est ce dont il est
question nous nous proposons aux
français aux étrangers de d'adhérer à la
France et ils font le choix en réalité
parce que qu'on le veuille ou non on a
aussi tout à fait la possibilité de
renoncer à la nationalité française la
position défendue par le rassemblement
national c'est
celle qui est contraire au génie de la
France et au génie de qui a été exprimé
par marché dans les avec Figaro qui dit
des aristocrates qu'est-ce que après
tout que vous vous êtes donné la peine
de naître et bien ces Français du
rassemblement national se sont donné la
peine de naître et ils sont tout pleins
de leur fierté de se donner la la peine
de naître mais sans grand génie pour
dire pour garder les mêmes mots de de
Figaro et ils n'ont jamais fait preuve
de leur grand génie en réalité et ils
trouvent bien suffisante cette donnée la
peine de naître pour revendiquer le
privilège d'être français et bien nous
nous considérons qu'être français c'est
effectivement une chance et nous ne
voulons pas en privé ceux qui n'ont pas
eu ceux qui ont eu la chance précisément
de naître sur notre sol alors je vais
mettre au voix les amendements de
suppression qui vote pour qui vote
contre ils sont adoptés ils font tomber
les amendements suivants ils suppriment
l'article 2 ter le de qu TER madame la
rapporteur le
1695 merci monsieur le Président donc en
fait cet article de quat il vient
rallonger les délais à partir desqueles
un étranger peut solliciter une
naturalisation par décret et cette
disposition consue une barrière
injustifiée à l'intégration et c'est
aussi un cavalier législatif et c'est
pour ça que je vous invite à supprimer
cet article le mien est défendu
également le
720 qui le défend il est défendu défendu
le 885 les socialistes qui le défend
madame caramoli oui oui tout à fait
monsieur le Président il faut il faut
quand même s'arrêter quelques secondes
sur cet sur cet article qui vise à
allonger donc le délai de résidence au
terme de la naturalisation qui peut-être
accordé
à merci à l'étranger résidant
habituellement en France de 5 à 10 ans
on voit ici encore que l'intérêt de
cette
mesure pose question puisqu'il s'agit
d'un du délai pour demander une
naturalisation et non pas pour l'obtenir
alors c'est pour cette raisonl nous
insistons finalement pour supprimer cet
article
dequat le suivant c'est le 1052 monsieur
Lucas alors Go oui
euh encore encore un article qui n'a pas
de lien avec le texte qui est de
modification du code civil qui augmente
en délai sans aucune justification
disant pourquoi pas 100 ans après tout
euh sans lien avec le texte initial donc
encore une fois il y a urgence à le
supprimer le suivant c'est celui de
Madame fossillon oui merci Monsieur le
le président donc nous sommes évidemment
pour pour la suppression de cet article
qui entend durcir l'accès à la
nationalité on voit bien encore qu'on
est à la fois dans une mesure
d'affichage mais aussi dans dans une
longue liste de mesures en fait qui qui
tourne le dos à à notre ambition
d'intégration et et et d'intégration par
la naturalisation ou d'intégration par
le titre de séjour dans dans notre
société et dans notre nation et on voit
en plus que euh euh aujourd'hui dans les
préfectures pour pouvoir accéder à la
naturalisation déjà avec ce délai de 5
ans euh les délais justes d'instruction
allongent déjà considérablement le
moment où vous pouvez prétendre et
accéder à cette naturalisation donc on
on est sur sur une mesure à mon avis
totalement à la fois disproportionnée et
injuste et nous nous y opposons
vigoureusement madame
Brard oui quelques mots pour ajouter à
ce qui vient d'être précment
précédemment dit euh une procédure de
naturalisation ça va aussi surtout bien
au-delà d'un seul critère de durée de
résidence qu'on met à 5 10 ans c'est
aussi vraiment montrer une
volonté de de s'intégrer de de
s'assimiler euh à à la nation française
avec une connaissance on en a parlé
aussi longuement de la langue de
l'histoire de notre culture donc voilà
c'est aussi une des raisons pour
lesquelles il est souhaitable de
supprimer cet article Madame Dupont le
1333 madame gevnou le
1556 madame la rapporteur votre avis est
favorable madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président alors
encore une fois une partie des
macronistes la nuupess sit pour
assouplir le texte sortie du scénat ce
qui vous plaît pas ici c'est qu'on est
allongé à 10 ans donc on est passé de 5
ans à 10 ans la durée de résidence
nécessaire sur le territoire pour
solliciter une naturalisation mais une
naturalisation ça n'est pas un acte
anodin ça change votre vie ça change
aussi la vie de vos enfants au
rassemblement national nous sommes
favorables auou maintien de ces 10 ans
parce que il s'agit d'une durée
suffisante pour apprécier les liens que
l'étranger entretient avec la France et
10 an ça n'est pas une durée incohérente
puisque cela correspond au délai de
validité d'une carte de résident et
c'est ce qui peut se pratiquer chez
certains de nos voisins européens par
exemple en Espagne dont le gouvernement
est socialiste donc il n'y a rien
d'affreux dans cette proposition et
c'est la raison du dépôt de notre
amendement de
suppression merci monsieur le Président
j'ai vraiment je n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment quand on dit qu'on
aime notre pays on peut vouloir que des
gens qui ont envie de devenir Français
ne le deviennent pas ou qu'on
complexifie le fait qu'il devienne
français c'est c'est quelque chose qui
est sidérant pour moi enfin quand on
aime son pays et son peuple le fait que
des gens veuent faire partie de notre
nation c'est normalement quelque chose
de positif on se dit tiens voilà un
français de plus bienvenue dans la
communauté nationale et figurez-vous que
le délai actuellement c'est 5 ans là il
est proposé de faire 10 ans c'est
n'importe quoi mais des délais dans
l'histoire républicaine de notre pays il
y en a eu plein 1793 c'était un an 1848
c'était 6 mois et puis après il y a eu
toute une baston autour de la loi des
burgves qui voulait faire passer ça à 3
ans mais en 1848 pour la petite histoire
on a quand même naturalisé les étrangers
qui avaient participé à la révolution
vous voyez à quel point vous vous
éloignez de l'histoire républicaine et
révolutionnaire de notre pays vraiment
apprenez l'histoire de France si vous
voulez être utile à la
patrie cet amendement de suppression qui
vote pour qui vote contre il est adopté
il fait tomber les amendements suivants
et il supprime l'article de quatire le 2
ququ madame la rapporteur merci monsieur
le Président donc nous terminons la
série d'amendements sur le droit de la
nationalité qui ont été ajouté par le
Sénat avec cet amendement qui augmente
le droit de terme des demandes de
naturalisation et de réintégration dans
la société française donc j suis opposé
pour deux raisons mais cela ne vous
surprendra pas sur le fond on voit bien
que ça représente quand même une
barrière financière importante et sur la
forme cette disposition et comme les
autres un cavalier législatif je vous
remercie j'ai un amendement identique
que je défends le
722 les insoumis qui alors c'est nous
nous allons dans le sens de de ce qui a
été dit effectivement donc vous avait
imaginé les uns et les autres tous les
empêchements possibles bon là on en
arrive effectivement à la barrière de
l'argent ça fait x 5 hein malgré tout
donc bon comme d'autres l'ont dit avant
en particulier madame Mame la rapporteur
hein bien sûr nous sommes tout à fait
d'accord avec
ça le suivant 886 pour les socialistes
madameer oui cet amendement vise à
supprimer l'article 2 quinquè qui
prévoit l'augmentation du droit de
timbre requis pour le dépôt d'une
demande de naturalisation ce droit de
timbre requis dans le cas d'une demande
de naturalisation passerait de 55 € à
250 on est toujours dans le régime de
l'inflation nous sommes toujours dans le
régime de l'inflation si on l'avait
oublié bien on le retrouve aujourd'hui
ici ici encore on comprend mal l'intérêt
d'une telle mesure qui discrimine sur le
fondement de l'aisance financière la
somme de 250 € peut-être dissuasive pour
un grand nombre de personnes qui sont
par ailleurs réellement désireuses
d'acquérir la nationalité française cet
article doit être
supprimé le 1169
madame
inflation allez-y ouais merci merci
monsieur le Président mais que s'est-il
passé au Sénat avec les article
précédent on on voyait déjà une volonté
de
restreindre le la nationalité uniquement
à ceux qui le méritaent puis à ceux qui
en faisaient expressément la demande
voilà maintenant qu'il faut en plus
avoir les moyens de payer un timbre de
250 € c'est quand même pas
rien et tout ça on nous explique qu'en
plus ce sont des cavalier législatif on
a rarement à l'Assemblée la possibilité
de passer autant d'articles autant
d'amendements qui sont sans lien avec le
texte et qui en plus sont d'une teneur
particulièrement incroyable donc bien
évidemment que nous nous opposons à cet
article et que nous en sollicitons la
suppression acquérir la nationalité
française ne devrait jamais être une
question de moyen une question de
finances il en va de l'esprit et des
valeurs de notre publ nous ne pouvons
pas laisser passer un tel
article madame Rocard le monsieur Mandon
le 1997 non non très rapidement encore
une fois tout a été dit mais moi je
trouve ça très très dommageable de
limiter la seule
intégration un montant de timbre fiscale
qu'on fasse FO 2 x 4 x 10 pour moi ça
n'a aucun sens ce n'est pas comme ça que
je veux qu'on
intègre et enfin Madame gous le
défendu alors madame la rapporteur votre
avis est favorable monsieur
nen merci monsieur le Président juste
pour dire qu'en effet passer de de 55 €
à à 250 est sans doute une une évolution
et une somme trop importante néanmoins
je tiens juste à signaler que le prix
n'a pas évolué depuis 2011 alors que
pour un passeport français le prix d'un
timbre d'un d'un passeport français
évolué de 60 € à 86 € récemment et donc
en fin de compte même si je dis qu'on
viens pas que passer de 55 à 250 est
bien trop important il y aurait
peut-être un intérêt à avoir une
certaine revalorisation qui soit en
cohérence avec le prix le prix d'un
timbre d'un passeport
français Monsieur
léomand Merci monsieur le Président je
dois dire que quand j'ai lu le projet de
loi issu du Sénat celui-ci cet article
là c'est celui qui m'a fait qui m'a fait
le plus rire parce que passer de 55 à
250 € le TH pour accéder à la
nationalité française il y avait que la
droite pour inventer ça la droite il y a
quelques années enfin il y a longtemps
ils avaient inventé le suffrage
sansitaire fallait avoir du fric pour
pouvoir voter et ben là ils ont inventé
la nationalité sans itire alors celle-là
fallait le faire franchement je crois
que ça sera la bonne blague du soir pour
finir la soirée heureusement qu'on va
repousser cette horreur donc je vais
mettre au voix cet amendement qui vote
pour qui V contre il est adopté donc il
supprime l'article 15 quiè il fait
tomber les amendements suivants et nous
on va pouvoir aller coucher et suspendre
cette séance on se retrouve demain à 9h
je souhaite une bonne nuit